Wie sollte es anders kommen? Natürlich trifft Edin Dzeko bei seinem ersten Spiel für Schalke 04. Jetzt ist nur noch die Frage, trägt er die Königsblauen auch zum Aufstieg? Und die zweite Frage, wie sind eigentlich die anderen Zweitligisten, die sind ja auch durchaus mal Thema, aus der Winterpause gekommen? Das bespreche ich nun mit Matthias Kneifl und Kevin Bublitz. Let's go! Jetzt nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Langeheil fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossi ist zu kurz ab, der lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin, Wagner.
Und das Anzündung.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Und damit ein herzliches Willkommen im Rasenfunk. Genauer gesagt in der Ligatur der 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Ja, auch wir sind jetzt zurück aus dem Winterschlaf, aus der Winterpause. Freue ich mich total drüber. Wer ich bin, vielleicht schalten ja auch das erste Mal Leute jetzt ein. Das ist ja immer so ein Startpunkt, so ein Beginn der… Oh, guck mal. Es ist live. Ich habe hier aus Versehen zweimal das Intro abgespielt. Fantastisch. Wir bleiben drauf. Ich muss auch erst mal wieder reinkommen. Bester Beweis. Mein Name ist Marc Schilzki. Ich führe heute wieder durch diese Zweitligasendung des Rasenfunk. Ich bin freier Journalist beim RBB zu lesen, bei Hertha Bays zu hören, aber eben auch hier im Wechsel mit der guten Eva. Und ich bin natürlich, wie immer, nicht alleine habe. Wunderbare Expertise an meiner Seite. Zum einen die Lilie des Rasenfunk, Matthias Kneifl vom Kickschuh-Blog und Podcast Hoch und Weit. Grüße dich. Hi.
Servus, hallo zusammen.
Hallo, hallo. Mit schönem neuen Mikro. Guck mal, die Allstars, die... Es ist immer noch Luft nach oben und wir nutzen jedes Potenzial aus. Ist das nicht schön? Und ansonsten natürlich Paderborn-Fan, Host des Padercasts und Stefan Teges Ultra, Kevin Bublitz.
Ich grüße dich. Ich dachte, jetzt kommt auch eine Blume. Danke. Hallo, grüße dich.
Ist Paderborn bekannt für eine Blume? Das wäre mir neu.
Ja, lass mir das.
Ich sage dir, in NRW wächst nichts. Was? Wir wollen heute über alles Mögliche reden, aber vor allen Dingen haben wir zwei Schwerpunkte in dieser Illustren-Sendung. Zum einen ist der Transferwinter im vollen Gange. Ihr werdet es durchaus mitbekommen haben. Und auch die Zweitligisten haben schon eifrig den Einkaufskorb gefüllt. Wir wollen über die Neuzugänge reden, die wir bislang am spannendsten fänden. Exzellent nicht unbedingt die größten Namen. Über einen großen Namen, um den kommen wir gar nicht hinweg. Aber nicht unbedingt die größten Namen, sondern die, wo wir sagen, es ist auf irgendeiner Perspektive sehr spannend, dass der jetzt da und da spielt. Und zum anderen sind nur zwei Spieltage der Rückrunde ins Land gezogen. Und wir wollen auf die Teams blicken, die in unseren Augen zumindest besonders positiv oder negativ aus der Winterpause gekommen sind. Bevor wir das aber tun, sprecht mir nach, wie immer der Hinweis. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Er finanziert sich allein durch die Spenden der HörerInnen, beispielsweise durch dieses Mal Lennart, Wunderheiler, Michael, Quasi83 und Steffen. Sie alle unterstützen diesen Podcast und sichern zum einen damit, dass Max seinen Lebensunterhalt damit bestreiten kann und dass auch Personen wie Eva oder ich moderativ hier auch mal andere Formate befüllen können und den Rasenfunk noch so viel bunter machen. Das ist auch wunderschön. All das macht ihr möglich durch eure Spenden. Wenn ihr das zum neuen Jahr als quasi Neujahrsvorsatz vielleicht umsetzen wollt und auch unterstützen wollt, dann schaut nochmal vorbei. Bei rasenfunk.de/supportersclubfindetihrnatürlich auch in den Show Notes den Link. So, ich würde sagen, wir beginnen jetzt mal darüber zu reden, was bislang so passiert ist auf dem Transfermarkt und ich habe es schon anklingen lassen, um einen Namen– kommen wir nicht herum– Edin Dzeko. Der Messias ist in Gelsenkirchen gelandet, so zumindest gefühlt die mediale Berichterstattung der letzten Tage und ich kann das natürlich auch verstehen. 39 Jahre alt, kehrt nach 15 Jahren nach Deutschland zurück, zwischendurch Stationen gehabt wie Manchester City, Inter Mailand, Dias, Roma, Fenerbahce, aber zuletzt dann auch die Fiorentina. Da lief es so semigut davor, allerdings umso besser, überall Meister geworden, teilweise Torschützenkönig geworden. Einer der treffsichersten Stürme der letzten 20 Jahre im europäischen Fußball. Das ist tatsächlich, muss er sich nicht verstecken, vor dem, weiß ich nicht, Suarez oder so, dieser Welt, was die reine Quote angeht. Und das ist schon bemerkenswert. Und dieser Mann, Matthias, ist jetzt in Gelsenkirchen gelandet. Was war vielleicht, bevor wir darüber reden, dass natürlich das Drehbuch perfekt wurde am jetzt Sonntag, was war deine erste Reaktion, als du mitbekommen hast, wow, das passiert ja wirklich.
Ja, das hatte schon so ein bisschen was von einem messy Moment in der MLS. Also, wenn man so die Berichterstattung rundherum betrachtet, das gab ja kaum noch ein anderes Thema. Also, hat alles überlagert und ist natürlich auch ein Name. Das lässt sich nicht leugnen. Hat auch so ein bisschen was Fußballromantisches, weil man hat ja jetzt tatsächlich auch mitbekommen, er hat sich selber ins Spiel gebracht, hatte viele Gespräche geführt mit Landsleuten, die Bundesliga-erfahren sind, wie er selbst ja auch, aber ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung aus der letzten Zeit hatten. Und dann kam eins zum anderen und er ist jetzt bei einem absoluten Traditionsclub, aber gleich wohl bei einem Gefallenen, wenn man so will, Traditionsclub gelandet, also auch das hat so was Cinderella-artiges. Und ich bin gespannt, wie es aufgeht, aber sounds weird, aber like a match, könnte man sagen, auch ohne den heutigen Treffer. Also da, glaube ich, ist schon was, was einfach Schalke auch braucht, weil ich hatte mir nach dem Spiel bei der Hatta am 18. Spieltag noch so gedacht, beim Blick auf das Spiel, aber auch auf die Tabelle mit 22 Toren, nach dann 18 Spieltagen Tabellenführer zu sein. Das spricht von einer enormen Effizienz, aber auch für viele knappe Ergebnisse. Und deshalb glaube ich, müssen sie einfach vorne schon nachlegen. Und jetzt haben wir heute noch gehört, dass Silla den Abflug macht, höchstwahrscheinlich in die USA und will sich da mal messig aus der Nähe angucken. Aber er hatte halt auch jetzt erst 4 Treffer und das war doch weniger als in der vergangenen Saison, als er mit 16 Treffern erst mal aufwarten konnte. Das heißt, wahrscheinlich das Spielsystem jetzt nicht unter Muslice so für ihn geeignet, wie es in der letzten Saison der Fall war. Und wenn er jetzt weg ist, dann mag das mit dem Dzeko-Anflug zusammenhängen, aber sie brauchen auch jetzt immer noch jemanden. Also sie müssen sich einfach an der Spitze breiter aufstellen und Dzeko ist ein alter Fahrensmann, der wird jetzt kein Umschaltspieler per se, aber ist, glaube ich, als Zielspieler geeignet, Bälle festzumachen, die Nachrücken dann ins Spiel zu bringen. Und wie man heute gesehen hat, wenn mal am Ende was gedreht werden muss, dann sind halt hohe Flanken oftmals das Stilmittel und damit ist er sicherlich nicht verkehrt. Insofern, große Name, große Verwunderung, aber ich glaube auch durchaus nachvollziehbar.
Du hast ja sehr viele sehr wichtige Punkte genannt. Erstmal quasi zu den Modalitäten. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass Hanfrak Baumann heute im Sky-Interview noch mal bestätigt, also Edin Dzeko hat sich Schalke quasi selbst angeboten. Er soll sich quasi mittendrin im Gehaltsgefüge befinden. Wenn zu hören ist, dass Karaman damit 800.000 Euro der Spitzenverdiener ist, können wir vielleicht von der Hälfte oder so ausgehen. Wobei Frank Baumann auch bestätigt hat, dass natürlich sowohl mit Florenz als auch mit Dzeko selbst sehr viele Boni vereinbart sind. Also sollte es zu Dingen kommen wie dem Aufstieg oder Ähnliches, da wird sicherlich noch mal einiges an Geld fließen. Aber dann hat Schalke dieses Geld dann ja auch. Und so ist es wohl so, dass er eher für den Spaß an der Sache noch mal spielt oder wie Sehat Kolasihanac gesagt hat, wenn du noch mal richtig was erleben willst, dann steig mit Schalke auf. Und für den Thrill geht es nach Gelsenkirchen. Du hast es auch schon erwähnt, Musa Zilla wird in die MLS wechseln, wahrscheinlich zu New York, wie es heißt. Da ist es wohl so, dass man bis zu 7 Millionen Euro inklusive Boni bekommen kann. Das ist ein stolzer Betrag für jemanden, wie du gesagt hast, Matthias, der in dieser Saison nur 4 Tore erzielt hat und gar nicht so sehr zum Stil des Trainers passt, wie ich finde. Und Edin Dzeko soll das sein, wenn vielleicht auch nicht immer über 90 Minuten was Zilla nicht sein konnte, quasi in der Körperlichkeit ein Verbindungsspieler. Das ist etwas, was sich Muslic von seinem Mittelstürmer sehr wünscht, weshalb auch, glaube ich, so Jomfi Brian Lasme, der ja auch vorher nicht so gut gelitten war auf Schalke, wichtig war, jemand, der körperlich da ist und es schafft, beizuhalten, so dass Mitspieler wie einen El Fawzi, einen Karaman, einen Younes nachrücken können und dort dann die nächste Angriffswelle starten. Das kann Edin Dzeko, glaube ich, auch immer noch sein. Er ist sportlich immer noch klasse, immer noch ein sehr guter Wand- wie Abschlussspieler, auch wenn es jetzt bei Florenz nicht so gut gelaufen ist, wobei man da auch einordnend sagen muss, bei Florenz ist es insgesamt nicht gut gelaufen. Die spielen eine Horrorsaison und da liegt es nicht an Edin Dzeko. Kevin, jetzt haben wir den besonderen Fall, dass er dann heute auch noch direkt gescord hat. Er kam in der 66. und 67. Minute rein und erzielte dann eben den Anschlusstreffer, der letztendlich dann zum 2 zu 2 führen sollte. Also ein bisschen vorausgeblickt. Frank Baumann hat schon bestätigt, dass neben ihm noch ein Mittelstürmer kommen soll. Trotzdem vielleicht eher Prognose. Was glaubst du denn, wie groß der sportliche Wert für Dzeko in der Rückgründe sein kann?
Tja, das ist die große Frage. Das ist die große Frage. Ich hab, als diese nostalgische Moment quasi ist, es ja eigentlich schon aufkam, hab ich mich an die Meistersorte des VfL Wolfsburg zurückgeinnert, als ich damals live vor Ort war und berichtet habe. Das war 2008, 2009. Das ist heftig, wie lang das her ist. Also fast 20 Jahre bald. Und damals hat er mit Grafit zusammen, wir beide zusammen, 54 Tore geschossen. Das ist immer noch, glaub ich, der Topwert für ein Sturmduo in der Bundesliga. Wie ihr beide schon gesagt habt, er kann der Unterschiedstyp sein, auch mit 39, glaube ich, noch. Ob er jedes Spiel über 90 Minuten performen wird, ist die Frage. Aber genau solche Sachen wie heute machen ihn natürlich wirklich, dafür ist er Gold wert. Also sie machen ihn wertvoll für die Mannschaft und natürlich sein ganzer Erfahrungswert. Die Aura, die er mitbringt, kann so eine Mannschaft mitziehen. Wir haben es natürlich auch schon erlebt, wenn so ein Spiel mit Star-Lyon kommt, kann das auch kontraproduktiv sein. Aber ich glaube, unter dem Setting, unter dem er jetzt gekommen ist, dass die Mannschaft schon oben mit drinsteht, er kommt dazu, strahlt einfach so ein bisschen Star-Power immer noch aus und kann die Mannschaft mitziehen, kann die gucken. Da sind sicherlich einige dabei, die so wie ich ihn noch von damals kannten aus dem TV oder von Erzählungen vielleicht manchmal auch. Da gibt es ja auch noch Spieler, die sind ja gerade geboren vielleicht. Ja, es ist spannend. Es ist wirklich eine ganz spannende Nummer. Ich finde es auch ein bisschen verrückt. So ein kleiner Mediengag weiß ich nicht, aber mit 39.
Das ist so ein Raoul-Moment nochmal.
Genau. Als Matthias vorhin Messi sagte, ich habe an Raoul eher gedacht, weil auf Schalke bietet sich an der Vergleiche. Du wolltest den wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht direkt zu machen, weil es so naheliegend war. Ja, ich finde es cool. Liga ist sowieso eine coole 2. Liga, also auch im internationalen Vergleich. Und wenn dann noch so ein Name dazu kommt, gibt es auch nochmal ein bisschen ein paar Leute, die wieder draufgucken. Er nimmt auch keinen Talent, glaube ich, den Platz weg, gerade beim FC Schalke 04. Insofern alles gut. Ich bin gespannt, wenn sie daneben stellen wollen. Ich meine, mit Ljubočić spricht man ja auch so richtig. Er ist ja der nächste Mittelfeldspieler, auch schon im Anflug in was eines Wortes gelandet. Der große Schlamann hatte vor Ort viel zu tun. Genau, da haben sie ja noch einen Spieler auch schon wieder dazu geholt, der dann das Team auch noch mal im Mittelfeld festigen soll. Mal gucken, was da jetzt noch passiert in der nächsten Woche.
Auch ja, aber Ljubočić angeblich für eine Million Euro, auch das, finde ich, ist ein bemerkenswerter Transfer. Der ist nicht ohne Grund lange Zeit sehr guter Bundesligaspieler gewesen. Oder zumindest sehr brauchbarer. Das ist natürlich auch die besondere Sogwirkung von Schalke 04. Und das ist das Fußballromantische an der Sache, dass dieser Glanz eines gefallenen Riesens trotzdem noch so groß ist, dass Spieler wie Edin Dzeko sich davon anziehen lassen.
Ich glaube, vor einem Jahr wäre er nicht gekommen.
Weil da atmosphärisch so viel kaputt war.
Ich glaube, es hat die Mannschaft jetzt, die jetzt gerade die Hinrunde gespielt hat, sich auch erarbeitet, dass dieser Glanz wieder angepinselt wurde an die Arena.
Definitiv.
Also, das bin ich bei dir. Schalke ist schon einfach ein Name. Das ist schon cool, wenn du mit 39 die Möglichkeit bekommst, noch mal auf der Bühne, vielleicht sogar dich noch mal in die Geschichtsbücher eines Vereins reinzuschreiben, indem du da mit dafür sorgst, in der Rückrunde, dass sie aufsteigen. Cool, coole Geschichte.
Ich denke auch, da hat man doch tatsächlich gesehen, dass am Anfang der Saison es erst mal darum ging, das System zu etablieren und es ging auf. Man hatte einen neuen Coach, man hatte jetzt keine wirklich supernamhafte Mannschaft und die hat sich jetzt so dermaßen an der Tabellenspitze festgebissen, dass jetzt glaube ich alle Verantwortlichen auch spüren, jetzt müssen wir es ziehen. Und im Endeffekt hat man jetzt eben mit den genannten Leuten zwei schon mal fix, also mit eben hier Edin Dzeko in aller erster Linie und Ljubicicija dann auch und dann wird womöglich noch ein wirklich anderer Stürmer kommen. Man hat aber auch mit Karjus im Tor und mit eben Dzeko im Sturm jetzt so zwei Kardinalpunkte und alte Fahrernsmänner an Bord. Sie können glaube ich auch, wenn irgendjemand mal anfängt, nervös zu werden im Kader sagen, hier, du machst dein Ding, sorgst dafür, dass du keine Fehler machst und werd nicht nervös, ich regle das und ich glaube, das kann schon mal gut sein.
Ja, so ein Karamann kann man da sicherlich auch nennen oder ein Kartisch, der auch gefühlt schon jede Schlacht geschlagen hat. Zumindest sieht er immer so aus. Ich glaube auch, dass dieser Push durch Edin Dzeko nicht zu unterschätzen ist, weil man schon das Gefühl hatte, ohne da zu negativ sein zu wollen, dass so ein paar Prozentpunkte in den letzten Spielen von Schalke vielleicht ein wenig gefehlt haben. Ich erinnere an das letzte Spiel vor der Winterpause gegen Braunschweig beispielsweise, wo du auch merkst, dass das System von Muzlic beruht darauf, zu 110 Prozent da zu sein. Nichts drunter. Ansonsten könnte es ein bisschen gefährlich werden. Ich glaube, wenn ein Spieler wie Dzeko dort landet, ist das ein großer emotionaler Push, sowohl für das Umfeld als auch die Mannschaft, dass man noch mal einen Drive für die Rückrunde kreieren kann. Ich glaube, dass es auch atmosphärisch, einfach neben der Klasse, die einen Edin Dzeko immer noch hat, eine sehr gute Verstärkung ist. Jetzt müssen wir gespannt sein. Er hat jetzt schon ein Rekord. Bestimmt gibt es schon 17 andere, die ich noch nicht nennen kann, weil ich sie noch nicht gesehen habe. Ein Rekord hat er aber schon mal pulverisiert. Er ist jetzt mit 39 Jahren, 10 Monaten und 8 Tagen der älteste Torstütze der 2. Bundesliga. Er löst einen gewissen Helmut Haller ab, der den 1979 aufgestellt hat. Ich kenne den Mann nur noch vom Namen her. Da bin ich ganz ehrlich, das ist nicht meine Generation. Dementsprechend hat Dzeko dann ja auch demnächst die Chance, in der Saison noch mit 40 Jahren ein Tor zu erzielen in der 2. Liga und könnte auch da noch mal eine Bestmarke mit aufstellen. Ansonsten bin ich, wie gesagt, sehr gespannt, wie das wird. Wir wollen jetzt aber eher weiterziehen. Das ist ja ein knackiges Format. Das soll nicht nur um Edin Dzeko gehen. Wir nehmen das Ganze jetzt mal zum Anlass, um darüber zu reden, was vielleicht noch für interessante Wintertransfers bislang in der 2. Liga getätigt wurden. Nicht im Sinne von, das sind die besten Wintertransfers, weil dann wird es vielleicht ein bisschen eintönig und langweilig, sondern eher, wie wir drei jeweils auf diesen Transfer blicken und irgendwas Spannendes erkennen oder sagen, das könnte vielleicht ein stiller Stabilisator sein oder was auch immer. Da wollen wir jetzt mal reingehen. Jeder von uns hat drei Spiele mitgebracht. Wir werden uns jetzt gegenseitig überraschen. Vielleicht doppeln sich Namen, aber das würde es ja nur weiter bekräftigen. Kevin, möchtest du vielleicht den Anfang machen? Wer ist dir da in den Sinn gekommen?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen auch rumgeguckt. Und jetzt wäre es natürlich einfach gewesen, wie gesagt, Edin Dzeko zu nehmen.
Habe ich extra aus der Verlosung genommen.
Den haben wir jetzt ja so gesehen auch genommen. Aber wenn man so ein bisschen rumguckt, ist immer, ja, kommt drauf an, wo man den Fokus drauflegt. Man könnte jetzt Amina Biedelfeld nehmen, die sich auch kurz gut oder zumindest namhaft verstärkt haben in der 2. Liga, aus Hannover z.B. Aber ich habe mir Hannover 96 auch anguckt, wie nach hinten, oder auch schon, falls du dich daran erinnerst, als ich so ein bisschen als Aufstiegsaspiranten koordinierte und habe da Noah Weishaupt, den sie ausgeliehen haben, vom SC Freiburg, der sicherlich schon absolutes Bundesliga-Format hat, aber in Freiburg nicht so wirklich irgendwie zum Zug kommt so richtig. Und finde ich schon, das ist auch eine namhafte Laie. Ist zwar nur eine Laie, aber trotzdem kann es Hannover 96 halt auch noch mal einen Impact irgendwie verleihen, finde ich. Also den finde ich auf dem Flügel sehr wichtig. Und ich meine, klar, sie haben dann auch noch Elia Saath geholt aus Augsburg. Also eigentlich haben sie schon klug, finde ich, sich verstärkt. Mal gucken, ob es dann auch fruchtet auf mittelfristige Sicht.
Wobei man sich bei Hannover so ein bisschen fragt, wie viele offensive Flügelspieler soll es noch sein.
Das stimmt. Da hast du den richtigen Punkt, ja.
Aber klar sind das Spieler, die sie definitiv verstärken können. Bei Weishaupt profitiert man, glaube ich, davon, dass der eine wirklich schlimme Laie zu Legia Varscha hatte. Fredi Bobic lässt grüßen. Das hat gar nicht funktioniert. Weshalb man ihn, glaube ich, jetzt bekommen hat, weil eigentlich wäre diese Laie ja bis zum Saisonende gewesen, aber das hat nicht funktioniert, sodass man die abgebrochen hat und dann jetzt weiter zu Hannover. Wie du sagst, der hat ja schon Bundesliganiveau nachgewiesen. Es gab schon Spiele bei Freiburg, wo ich das Gelingen hatte, okay, das ist jetzt wieder der nächste, den sie einfach irgendwie aus der eigenen Jugend ziehen und der relativ schnell Bundesliganiveau erreicht, dann vielleicht davon eben nicht profitiert, dass so Spieler wie Grifo und Kose sich aber eben nicht mal so eben verdrängen lassen und so ein bisschen aus der Verlosung geraten. Aber sicherlich ein Spieler, der bei einem Team wie Hannover einen Unterschied machen kann. Matthias, wen würdest du als erstes nennen wollen?
Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht gar so überraschend, weil er einfach an den ersten beiden Spieltagen schon auf sich hat aufmerksam machen können. Thomas Keller, Dresden. Verdammt, sticht. Er kam aus Heidenheim und ich hatte den immer mal ein bisschen wahrgenommen, aber ich hatte nicht mein Gesicht vor Augen offen gestanden.
Das ist so ein bisschen das Heidenheim-Phänomen, glaube ich.
Vielleicht auch das, genau. Er hat ja an den ersten beiden Spieltagen jeweils einen Treffer auflegen können oder eben erzielt als Innenverteidiger. Er hat damit auch nachhaltig zu Punktgewinnen beigetragen. Da werden wir nachher womöglich noch mal ein bisschen genauer drauf eingehen. Aber er hat die Abwehr sicherlich im Verbund mit dem, wie das System jetzt ausgerichtet ist, verstärkt. Da hat ja Dynamo in Summe auch gut zugelangt auf dem Transfermarkt. Aber er war sicherlich jetzt für das Erste ein wichtiger Faktor. Ich habe mich dann mal ein bisschen mit ihm noch auseinandergesetzt. Also er hat in Heidenheim bislang nur 540 Minuten gespielt. Und zwar nicht nur in dieser Saison, sondern in den letzten dreieinhalb Jahren. Und das ist außerordentlich. Also ich habe mal nachgeschaut, was da denn so der Grund war. Natürlich ein Kreuzbandriss. Ein Spieler mit Rhein, der ihn über ein Jahr lang hat aussetzen lassen. Dennoch in den dreieinhalb Jahren nur zweimal über die volle Distanz gespielt. Jetzt gleichwohl vor der Winterpause fünf Mal im Einsatz gewesen. Für Heidenheim nicht über die ganze Distanz, aber zumindest kam er für meinen Begriff näher an die Stammelf ran. Und dann ist es ja auch umso bemerkenswerter, dass er dann den Ausweg Dynamo gesucht hat, wo er nach langer Zeit einigermaßen anschlussfähig war. Und jetzt zeigt er einfach in Dresden, welche Qualität in ihm steckt. Also er ist zwar als Innenverteidiger eingesetzt, hat aber auch in Heidenheim sehr vereinzelt in den wenigen Einsätzen, auch im defensiven Mittelfeld spielen können. Also er sagt über sich selber, dass er ein gewisses Spielverständnis mitbringt. Ansonsten Robustheit und Zweikampfstärke und auch Sprungkraft schreibt er sich selber zu. Und ich denke, das hat man in den ersten zwei Spielen jetzt tatsächlich schon gesehen, dass er Dynamo mit stabilisiert und zu dem erfolgreichen Rückkundenstatt, denke ich, beiträgt.
Wie ich gesagt habe, Sticht. Ich habe ihn mir auch aufgeschrieben, weil er durch seine zwei Tore sicherlich sehr auffällig war. Zeitgleich aber, wie du sagst, Matthias, symbolisch dafür steht, wie Dynamo in dieser Rückrunde bislang agiert, nämlich defensiv so viel stabiler und cleverer als davor. Ich habe mir seine Zahlen auch mal angeguckt. Ein sehr sicheres, unaufgeregtes Passspiel, das passt hier wieder zum Spielverschändnis, also hat eine deutlich geringere Fehlerquote als seine Kollegen in den Wochen und Monaten zuvor. Und wie du sagst, Sprungkraft ist ein Thema, denn er ist– ich sage mal in Anführungsstrichen– nur 1,86. Für den Innenverteidiger jetzt nicht unbedingt das Top-Gardemas vielleicht, und trotzdem gewinnt er extrem viele Kopfball-Duelle. Wie gesagt, auch bei Standards gefährlich. Also auch das finde ich spannend und ich glaube, ich bin bislang fast der Königstransfer dieser 2. Liga. Wenn wir uns den sofortigen Impact angucken, ist das schon vorne wie hinten echt interessant. Also mit Keller aus dem Keller, wenn man so möchte. Ich würde direkt mal weitermachen und habe mich für einen Spieler entschieden, wieder eine Laie. Diesmal von Hoffenheim zu Kiel und ich rede über Umut Tuhumsu. Umut Tuhumsu ist ein Spieler, der von Hoffenheim zu Kiel verliehen wurde, gerade einmal 21 Jahre alt. Und ich sage es vorweg, für mich vom Skill-Set her ein Spieler, der definitiv nicht in die 2. Bundesliga gehört. Der das ja auch schon bewiesen hat. Also der hat nicht wenige Bundesligaspiele schon gemacht. Der hatte in der vorletzten Saison 20 Einsätze, in der letzten 12. Jetzt hatte er aber nur das Problem, dass sich andere Spieler bei Hoffenheim sehr in den Vordergrund gespielt haben. Am Avtolao im Mittelfeld, im Burche im Mittelfeld. Und da ist er so ein bisschen hinten dran geraten, was aber nun wirklich keine Schande ist. Und ich glaube, da hat sich sehr plötzlich dann einfach ein Leihfenster aufgemacht für einen Zweitligisten. Aber wie gesagt, eigentlich finde ich, dass der in die 1. Liga gehört. Das liegt daran, dass er technisch herausragend gut ist. Der hat eine super Übersicht und auch einen mutigen Spielstil. Also ich habe mir ein paar Szenen auch angeguckt, jetzt wo er für Kiel gespielt hat. Der dreht sich so wunderbar auf. Der hat so ein progressives Spiel, das tut den richtig gut. Und er ist ja jetzt quasi das neue Herzstück zusammen mit einem Jonas Meffert, der nach Kiel zurückgekehrt ist. Meffert eher für die Drecksarbeit, Tumshu für das spielerische. Der hat Kiel erkannt, dass das bislang nicht gut funktioniert hat mit den vorherigen Neuzugängen, die sich alle so ein bisschen an den deutschen Fußball noch gewöhnen müssen, habe ich das Gefühl. Und da ist Tumshu, finde ich, ein Faustpfand. Und jetzt hat Kiel 4 Punkte aus den zwei Spielen geholt. Wir haben sie heute noch nicht dabei, weil ich noch nicht so genau weiß. Ich brauche noch mehr Samplesize quasi, um zu sehen, wo uns für Kiel so ein bisschen geht. Finde ich noch ein bisschen nicht greifbar genug. Aber greifbar ist definitiv, dass Tumshu eine fantastische Verstärkung für einen Zweitligisten ist. Und das beweist er gerade. Und dann, selbst wenn es nächste Saison nicht bei Hoffenheim weitergehen sollte, sehe ich den trotzdem in irgendeiner ersten Liga, weil der einfach so gut ist.
Ich finde es auch aus seiner Basis heraus einen sehr cleveren Wechsel, muss ich sagen. Weil er war ja auch bei einem der großen Istanbuler Vereine im Gespräch. Liegt vielleicht für türkische Spieler auch nahe. Aber er hat sich bewusst für Kiel entschieden, nach allem, was ich gelesen habe. Kommt auch nicht so überraschend, weil eben mit Marcel Rabda ein Trainer am Werk ist, den er auch aus Hoffenheimer Zeiten schon kennt. Oder sie sind sich zumindest bekannt. Und ich denke, wenn er einen Trainer hat, der seine Skills zu schätzen weiß und nicht mal nur so sagt, es könnte funktionieren, sondern er weiß schon, was er kriegt und kann ihn dann dementsprechend auch sehr gut in seinen Teamgefüge einbauen, dann war das für mich ein sehr, sehr triftiger Wechsel. Und in dem halben Jahr kann er sich dann auch in der zweiten Liga wieder die Selbstsicherheit holen, die womöglich in etwas abhandengekommen ist. Und ich denke, wie du sagst, da liegt viel erstmal auf dem Feld sozusagen, was er dann auch tatsächlich dem Mannschaft geben kann. Und wieder entweder sich für andere Erstligisten womöglich interessant machen oder eben gestärkt nach Hoffenheim zurückkehren. Also finde ich einen schlauen Schachzug.
Kevin, wer wäre dein nächster Spieler?
Ja, es fällt schwer, weil er ja noch nicht gespielt hat. Aber ich bin tatsächlich gespannt auf Ljubicic beim FC Schalke 04. Ich glaube, das könnte so eine Schlüsselverpflichtung sein, die Schalke noch dann auch defensiv gesehen. Ja, also wenn das Spiel gegen Lauterneut so ein bisschen... Ich habe es natürlich bei Paderborn gespielt, habe nicht 90 Minuten gesehen. Aber das, was ich gesehen habe, waren sie defensiv schon noch ein bisschen anfällig. Und Ljubicic, wenn er so an seine alte Form, nenne ich es jetzt mal, rankommt, könnte das Schalke so der insgeheime Schlüsseltransfer sein, so in der Deckung hinter Dzeko. Ich finde, er könnte das Mittelfeld nochmal einen ordentlichen Zugewinn bekommen, einen ordentlichen Push bekommen. Bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Also gerade auch im Defensivverhalten dann. Offensiv sicherlich auch, aber ich glaube, wichtiger noch für die Schalke ist einfach, dass man dieses überfallartige, was Kais Lauterner zum Beispiel auch teilweise an einen Tag gelegt hat, wo sie einfach demonstriert haben, dass Schalke da anfällig ist. Ich glaube, ich kann mal mit einem Ljubicic, der wieder in den Tritt kommt, ganz gut auffangen. Ein Spieler, der von der Anlage her gut nach Darmstadt gepasst hätte.
Ja, wir haben da einen Herrn Schmidt geholt, Niklas Schmidt, der durchaus auch kreativ ist. Aber ich denke, da war bei uns der Neat nicht so sehr in der Form.
Der Ljubicic ist wirklich ein Spieler, an den hatte ich mich zwischenzeitlich in Köln echt verliebt, weil ich finde, der hat so wunderbare Box-to-Box-Qualitäten. Der kann im Defensiv ganz viel geben. Das ist ein irrer Arbeiter, der super viele Meter macht. Toller Pressingspieler. Deswegen ja auch gut zu Steffen Baumgart gepasst. Aber eben jemand, der offensiv immer seine Momente hat. Der geht aus jeder Saison eigentlich immer mit drei bis fünf Toren raus und legt auch mal einen auf. Er hat auch in der Europa League jetzt diese Saison und sieben Spielen zwei Tore erzielt. Also auch nicht der kleinste Wettbewerb. Das heißt, das ist schon jemand, der dir vielleicht auch, wo du gucken kannst, ob der auf der Sechs spielen soll. Da ist man mit Schallenberg und Elpharousi ja sehr gut besetzt. Oder ob er vielleicht sogar neben Karaman auf dieser Zehnerposition mit agieren soll. Da spielt nämlich gerade Armin Younes, der auch in diesen zwei Spielen, ehrlich gesagt, jetzt sehr untergegangen ist. Also ich finde es löblich, dass Muzlic die anscheinend sehr guten Trainingsleistungen eines Younes anerkennt und ihn nicht aussortiert und sagt, okay, dann kriegst du jetzt deine Chance. Wir wollen ja mehr Kreativmomente in der Rückrunde. Das ist aber, ich habe es ja gegen Berlin 90 Minuten gesehen und jetzt in der Konferenz, das ist gar nicht aufgegangen. Und im Pressing funktioniert Younes eher schlecht bis gar nicht. Das heißt, mit Jubicic hast du da noch eine Möglichkeit, zumal Schalke nach wie vor massive Verlustungsprobleme hat, wenn man sich diese Bank anguckt. Wow, also da ist fast kein Spieler dabei jetzt gewesen, außer Edin Dzeko, ein Walentovic und noch ein Felipe Sanches. Sind da sonst keine Spieler, wo du sagst, ah ja, das ist ad hoc eine Verstärkung, wenn die aufs Feld kommen. Allein da rotieren zu können in diesem intensiven Musichsystem und zu sagen, vielleicht mal, keine Ahnung, LVU, vielleicht heute mal ab der 60. Ist natürlich immens viel wert. Also deswegen glaube ich auch, dass es ein wahnsinnig guter Schachzug ist.
Bringt auch diese, das ist jetzt sehr abgedroschen, aber die typischen Schalke-Tugenden auch mit, Kämpfer, Arbeiter, aber gleichzeitig trotzdem auch jemand, der die Leute begeistern kann, mitnehmen kann. Das, was immer wieder das Kriterium auch für Schalke-Spieler war, die dann auch es geschafft haben, auf Schalke eine gute Leistung zu bringen. Wie gesagt, es ist jetzt viel Kaffeesatzleserei, aber ich glaube schon, ich bin gespannt, kommt von Dino Mosagreb, ne? Also, wie du sagst, ich glaube nicht, dass er Schalke schaden wird, sondern eher den Kater sehr klug aufwerten wird auch.
Und er weiß, wie man aufsteigt. Hat er mit dem FC geschafft.
Stimmt.
Matthias, wer ist dein nächster Spieler?
Ich nehme David Mogwa, der jetzt quasi die Aufgabe hat, Ebeneutalib zu ersetzen. Also, da geht es eher darum, wird es aufgehen oder wird es nicht aufgehen. Also, er tritt in große Fußstapfen, aber das tun gefühlt alle, die nach Elbersberg kommen und dann plötzlich zum Rising Star werden. Also, es ist auf jeden Fall eine große Aufgabe. Wir erinnern uns letztes Jahr an der Winterpause. KSC war gut im Rennen, Ville Ziftilatze nach Heidenheim und war dann plötzlich nicht mehr so konkurrenzfähig. Ich traue es Elbersberg zu, dass es diesen Verlust im Kollektiv auffangen würde. Aber dennoch sind 13 Torbeteiligungen, die Eben Talib hatte, bei damals, zum 17. Spieltag, 31 Toren. Das heißt, 42% aller Tore waren irgendwie mit seinem Beisein verbunden. Und das gilt es schon, irgendwie aufzufangen. Mal schauen. Also der Vorteil von Mokwa ist sicherlich, dass auch er den Trainer kennt und der Trainer kennt ihn. Also Vincent heißt er, Vincent Wagner. Genau. War ja in Hoffenheim lange Zeit Trainer und hat dann auch ihn trainiert. Da hatte er seinen Gehörigenbeitrag dazu geleistet, dass sie aus der Regionalliga in die 3. Liga aufgestiegen sind. Und im Kicker stand irgendwann mal so um den Jahreswechsel herum, dass Wagner glaubt, dass Mokwa schon durch die Zeit, die sie gemeinsam in Hoffenheim verbracht haben, sehr viel schneller integriert werden kann, als es bei anderen Neuzugängen der Fall wäre. Er hat auch gesagt, Eben-Utalib hätte in etwa drei Monate in der Vorbereitung gebraucht, bis er gewusst hat, wie die Laufwege sind bei Elbersberg. Und bei Mokwa in Hoffenheim hätte es ein Jahr gedauert. Und deshalb glaubt er, das dauert jetzt nicht mehr so lange, sondern das ist an der Stelle relativ schnell klar, wie Elbersberg spielen will und dass Mokwa da an der Stelle nicht so lange fremdelt. Gleichwohl sind sie, zumindest von der Erscheinung her, ziemlich unterschiedliche Stürmertypen. Also Epenut Alib über 1.90, Mokwa gerade mal 1.80. Gleichwohl, wenn man die Daten aus der 3. Liga sich zu Rate zieht, wo er jetzt auch eine Hinrunde gespielt hat. Rechts wie links gleichermaßen abschlussstark. Auch schon zwei Kopffalltore. Also ich denke, Elbersberg wird niemanden jetzt wirklich holen, von dem sie nicht in Ansätzen was sehen, was total Hanebüchen ist. Deshalb bin ich primär gespannt und habe ihn deshalb genannt, wie er Elbersberg verstärken wird oder den Ausfall verschmerzen lässt oder ob er ihnen einfach noch mal eine andere Facette gibt.
Total spannend. Also er hat in der letzten Saison 26 direkte Torbeteiligung gehabt in der Regionalliga, jetzt in acht Drittligaspielen drei Tore erzielt. Wie du sagst, jemand, der die Wagner-Schule kennt, jetzt in zwei Spielen auch direkt gestartet ist. Da vertraut man ihm also direkt, aber der jeweils ohne Torbeteiligung geblieben ist, was merkt ihr auch so optimal?
Genau, sie haben auch für ihn in die Tasche gegriffen. Normalerweise sind ja Leihgeschäfte das Mittel der Wahl gewesen. Jetzt haben sie natürlich über den Ebeneutalib-Transfer erst mal Millionenchen zur Hand. Und da haben sie jetzt zwei davon glatt wieder investiert in die Verpflichtung von Mokwa, selbst wenn Hoffenheim sich da eine Rückkaufoption wohl hat zusichern lassen. Das bedeutet, die sehen auch was in ihm. Er hat ja auch letztes Jahr schon europäisch gespielt und das sogar zweimal getroffen, einmal gegen Tottenham. Also ein Spieler, one to watch, würde man sagen. Und sind wir mal gespannt, wie er sich in der 2. Liga, in der Wohlfühloase Elversberg schlagen wird.
Ja, das ist so. Das ist so. Die Wintervorbereitung natürlich kürzer als die Sommervorbereitung. Du hast es schon gesagt. An sich kennt er das System und die Laufwege. Und trotzdem ist es eine andere Vorbereitung, so reinzukommen als im Sommer, glaube ich, für ihn. Wie gesagt, Elversberg jetzt auch suboptimal gestartet mit einem Punkt aus zwei Spielen. Ich bin wirklich auch sehr schnell gespannt, wie schnell. Das Schöne bei Elversberg in dem Sinne ist, es gibt keinen Druck. Selbst wenn die in den nächsten vier Spiele nicht gewinnen, wird keiner sauer. Das Aufschicksiel ist jetzt, glaube ich, nicht so groß. Das ist eher ein, wenn es passiert, nehmen wir es. Und wenn nicht, ist es auch voll okay. Das sollte ihm zumindest die Ruhe geben, dass er jetzt nicht innerhalb der nächsten vier Spiele sofort knipsen muss. Auch wenn irgendwann das immer in den Kopf eines Stürmers gerät. Bin ich auch sehr gespannt. So, mein dementsprechend dritter Spieler ist, weil Thomas Keller ist ja dann auch schon abgehakt, ist ein weiterer zentraler Mittelfeldspieler, der in diesem Winter der erste Transfer von einem gewissen Sven Nislindt hat war, und zwar Satoshi Tanaka. Er ist für 900.000 Euro zu Fortuna Düsseldorf gewechselt, kam aus Hiroshima, hat bereits ein A-Länderspiel für Japan gemacht und ist im defensiven Mittelfeld, was ja, finde ich, die größte Problemzone der Hinrunde war bei Düsseldorf, da konnte man permanent einfach durchbrechen. Ich ja nämlich an Hanebüchen auftritte, beispielsweise gegen Nürnberg. Da ist er jetzt sofort gesetzt. Er ist zum einen super zweikampfstark, toller Arbeiter, gibt dem Spiel sehr viel Stabilität und Intensität, aber gleichzeitig ist das auch ein guter Fußballer. Also er versteht schon das Spiel, der agiert sauber und hat dementsprechend auch eine gewisse Pressing-Resistenz. Ja, 23 Jahre alt, ich habe es gesagt, 900.000 Euro, das ist zwar nicht wenig Geld für einen Zweitligisten, trotzdem jetzt aber auch keine Monstersumme. Es gibt das Gerücht, dass er auch jetzt schon eine Ausstiegsklausel hat, besonders für englische Vereine, weil ein gewisser anderer Tanaka ja diesen Weg auch gegangen ist, von Düsseldorf zu Lietz. Übrigens nicht verwandt, das ist klar. Aber Satoshi Tanaka ist glaube ich zum einen von der Position her einfach extremst wichtig gewesen und zum anderen aber auch in der individuellen Qualität ein Spieler, der sofort auf Zweitliganiveau funktionieren sollte. Da haben sich in den letzten Jahren ja auch immer wieder Japaner hervorgetan. Matthias, ihr habt ja auch einen bei Darmstadt, der das sehr gut macht, der jetzt auch diesen Spieltag getroffen hat. Das heißt, es ist anscheinend ganz Akiyama, das ist ein ganz guter Fit. Also Satoshi Tanaka ist glaube ich, es könnte so ein stiller Königstransfer sein, weil er glaube ich Düsseldorf in dieser Rückrunde massiv stabilisieren wird und so glaube ich so leise so ein paar Mehrpunkte runterpurzeln werden, als sie es in der Hinrunde in knappen Spielen getan haben.
Es ist mir tatsächlich letzte Woche gegen Bielefeld aufgefallen. Also noch nicht so, dass ich sonderlich viel über ihn sagen könnte, aber die Anlagen, die du gerade beschreibst, die waren glaube ich schon zu erkennen. Also sicherlich spannender Spieler. Und erstaunlich, wie schnell Japaner sich einfach auch in Europa zurechtfinden und auch eben in der zweiten Liga, weil auch Akiyama von Darmstadt keinerlei Erfahrungen mit Fußball außerhalb von Europa oder von Japan hatte und sich sofort als Verstärkung entpuckt hat. Also die bringen viel von ihrer Mentalität mit, was ihnen so ein Wechsel erleichtert.
Düsseldorf ist ja auch ein besonderer Standort für Japaner durch die große Community. Wie gesagt, da hat sich auch ein Tanaka hervorgetan, hinter Apple Camp ist zumindest halb Japaner. Ich erinnere mich natürlich auch an den– wie heißt der Gute von Hannover, der letzte Saison bei Casas-Lauton noch gespielt hat? Ich gucke live nach. Yokota, da ist Jokiel Yokota. Gleichzeitig ja auch deren Rechtsverteidiger. Ist ja auch Matsuda auch sofort eingeschlagen bei Hannover. Also die Quote ist hoch. Da sollten, glaube ich, mehr Zweitligisten hingucken.
Ist aber auch ein Charakteristikum, was man japanischen Spielern schon lange Zeit immer nachsagt, dass sie sehr gut zum europäischen Fußball passen und gleichzeitig mit ihrer Disziplin auch sich sehr gut integrieren und gut den Mannschaftsgefüge integrieren und Spielsysteme gut lesen können, weil sie auch sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr stark ausgebildet werden in Japan. Und die japanische J-League hat ja auch lange Zeit viele ältere deutsche Spieler dorthin geholt, um auch quasi Wissenstransfer nach Japan zu holen. Also ich glaube, das ist halt, und wie du sagst, eine starke Community auch in Deutschland, gerade in Düsseldorf, ist schon so eine, naja, man will es nicht überbewerten, aber schon auch so eine seelische Verwandtschaft im Sinne des Fußballs.
Ja, Kevin, du hast noch einen Spieler, oder bin ich jetzt gerade?
Ja, Tanaka hatte ich tatsächlich, den habe ich aber gestrichen nach den 2 ersten Spielen von Fortuna. Ben Justus Bobzin, oder wie ich es gerade ausgesprochen habe.
Ich finde, das Bobzin ist natürlich ein perfekter Wintertransfer.
Oh, da hat kurz gedauert bei mir.
Danke, danke.
Sehr gut. Weil der für mich auch ein Statement ist, meins, unnationale Spieler und so weiter, alles Mögliche. Also jetzt nicht viele. Ich finde vom Set ganz cool, dass so ein Offensiv-Allrounder als großes Talent gilt. Für die 1. Liga ist es vielleicht gerade noch ein bisschen zu früh. Oder auch da sind Spielernwege. Und das tut ihm, glaube ich, richtig gut, jetzt mindestens ein halbes Jahr 2. Liga zu spielen. Und er fügt sich halt auch sehr, sehr gut bei Dürrem und Dresden ein. Er hat so ein bisschen– es wird jetzt auch nicht überwärt nach der kurzen Zeit, aber muss man sich ja gucken, wie sich das jetzt gegen stärkere Mannschaften dann auch entwickelt. Aber in diesen beiden Spielen war es schon so, dass mal wieder Dynamik im Spiel von Dynamo war nach vorne. Das hast du direkt gemerkt und denke, da ist er sicherlich auch ein Spielertyp, der dann Spielfreude mit reinbringt. Find ich schon eine sehr, sehr wichtige Verpflichtung. Ja, also es ist so unter dem Ding Effekt-Transfer oder wie auch immer man das nennen möchte, der direkt halt auch funktioniert, direkt im Team ist. Ja, und mit Keller vielleicht zusammen einfach nochmal die nötige Spannung ins Team auch gebracht hat so. Nachdem wir nachher hier nun schon sehr viele disillusioniert waren, auch im Umfeld, hast du ja jetzt ja zumindest mit diesen beiden Mannschaften gegen, äh, beiden Spielen gegen direkte Konkurrenten ja nochmal so eine Aufbruchstimmung quasi erzeugt.
Diese Überleitung muss ich annehmen. Ja, dachte ich mir, deswegen steht die hier auch so. Perfekt, guck mal, perfekt, der Mann ist vorbereitet stark. Nehmen wir die Überleitung doch und reden dann jetzt tatsächlich dann über unsere, ja, ich glaube, ich hätte noch meinen Neuzugang Nummer 3. Oh Gott, dann ja, alles zurück.
Den hättest du in der Reihenfolge vorher bleiben müssen.
Selbst wenn das Feld bereitet war, aber ich muss noch mal reingrätschen. Und mein letzter Pick ist kein typischer Transfer, es ist Pete Scopel von Nürnberg.
Pete Scopel, jawoll.
Genau, also er kam ja schon im Sommer, ist aber da noch bei der 2. erst mal angetreten und ist jetzt, glaube ich, wie Phoenix aus der Asche in die Profimannschaft von Nürnberg eingezogen und könnte ihn viele Probleme lösen. Also ich habe letzte Woche gedacht, wer ist das? Also ich habe selten Debutanten so ultra präsent gesehen. Bei dem Spiel gegen Elbersberg hat 12 Torabschlüsse und er war ja quasi erst ein bisschen der Pechvogel, nachdem er einen Abpraller von der Latte nicht im Tor unterbringen konnte per Kopf, aber dann machst du es in der zweiten Halbzeit besser und er war einfach so ein Faktor in diesem Spiel. Das fand ich gerade gegen Elbersberg schon sehr, sehr bemerkenswert und auch, wenn man sich seinen Werdegang anguckt, also er ist jetzt gerade mal 20, aber er hat seine erste Station in dem Erwachsenenfußball war Landesliga, dann Oberliga Hamburg, dann jetzt Regionalliga, eine Halbserie und jetzt Zweite Liga und er hat, glaube ich, mit Klose so ein bisschen ein Bruder im Geiste auf der Trainerbank, also auch jemand, der sich über Umwege in den Profifußball und noch zu Höherem durchgeboxt hat und er hat auch wohl kein LZ von innen gesehen. Klose sagt auch über ihn, dass er quasi beidfüßig sei, ein brutal gutes Kopfbeispiel, hätte ein gutes Näschen für Positionierung, gleichwohl körperlich und noch ein paar Defizite, aber ich denke, das lässt sich beheben und sagt auch, dass er so alles aufsaugt und sich erarbeitet, also Klose übers Gobel, was ihn wiederum auszeichnet und ich glaube, das ist wirklich so ein Spieler, der Klose sehr taugt und jetzt bin ich wirklich gespannt, ob er diesen Raketenstart zunächst im Testspiel gegen die Grashoppers, zwei Tore und eine Vorlage, dann eben gegen Elbersberg, Match-Winner und gegen Darmstadt, konnte ich ihn jetzt am Freitag im Stadion sehen, da hat er jetzt natürlich nicht mehr so sehr auf sich aufmerksam machen können, weil das einfach auch mit zwei großen Innenverteidigern zu tun hat und das war in dem Fall dann eben Patrick Pfeiffer. Aber auch da war schon zu sehen, dass er auch mit dem Ball am Fuß was anfangen kann. Also er ist glaube ich einer, der viel mitbringt, der lange unentdeckt war und einer sein kann, der in Nürnberg den richtigen Verein gefunden hat, um vielleicht anderswo dann für ein bisschen Geld aufzuschlagen. Also wollen wir nicht zu viel versprechen, aber fette Props gehen auch raus an Club Fats, Reunited, den Blog, der schon vor dem Elbersberg-Spiel gesagt hat, the time is now und die haben quasi alles prophezeit, was seither eingetreten ist. Also fast schon prophetischer Text und deshalb, glaube ich, können wir damit die Transferkiste zumachen.
Aber jetzt bin ich doppelt froh, dass wir dich nicht ausgelassen haben, weil Piz Gobel muss ja Erwähnung finden. Allein wegen des Names. Ich finde ihn fantastisch. Und dazu, wie du sagst, ein sehr guter Junge, der von Klose sehr gelobt wird. Er meint, das ist fantastisch, wie er sich innerhalb... Also, er trainiert mit den Profis quasi seit ungefähr einem halben Jahr oder etwas länger. Und was der seitdem aufgesaugt hat, meint Klose, ist absolut fantastisch, hat sich sehr verbessert in einigen Bereichen. Saugt das auf, wie du gesagt hast, und belohnt sich jetzt dafür. Ist ja so eine Nordpflanze, also gebürtiger Pinneberger. Und zumindest war er drei Jahre bei St. Pauli. Von 2017 bis 2020 war er bei St. Pauli, aber das war ja noch relativ früh. Ob das jetzt schon NLZ ist, weiß immer gar nicht, wo das...
Wahrscheinlich dann doch....
in der Weiterstufe beginnt. Aber ansonsten hat er dann eher Union-Tornisch, 1-Büttler-TV mitgenommen. Also wirklich nicht der klassische Weg. Und, ja, ich meine, Nürnberg nun wirklich dafür bekannt. Jetzt haben sich das Image erarbeitet, solch jungen Spielern dann ja eine Chance zu geben. Gegen Darmstadt startete ja auch der gerade mal 18-Jährige, ich glaube, wie heißt der links Verteidiger, der gespielt hat?
Postner oder sowas?
Erik Postner. Also, sind dafür ja schon bekannt. Und da ist Pizgobe ein weiterer in dieser Erzählung.
Selbst Postner hat ja nur einen anderen Youngster verdrängt, weil er die fünfte gelbe Karte bekommen hat. Also, das heißt, Nürnberg ist wirklich eine spannende Mannschaft. Sollte man gucken, wo es die hin verschlägt. Und haben zumindest in Darmstadt auch, für meine Begriffe, ein wirklich gutes Spiel gezeigt. Unterwert geschlagen dann.
So, über Nürnberg werden wir sicherlich in der nächsten Sendung bestimmt auch noch mal reden. Jetzt wollen wir aber tatsächlich mal in die Teams reinstarten, über die wir heute reden wollen, die einen entweder auffällig positiven oder auffällig negativen Start in der Rückrunde hatten. Und wir haben jetzt den Namen schon sehr oft genannt und wollen jetzt noch mal etwas ausführlicher darüber reden. Dynamo Dresden. Ja, da ist einiges passiert. Die haben die Hinrunde noch als Tabellenletzter beendet. Reaktion sah so aus, 6 Neuzugänge hinter Wintertransferperiode, 5 davon Laien. Kevin, du hast es schon gesagt. Sofort-Effekt will man sich da holen, ob es ein Keller ist, ein Sterner, ein Robert Wagner, der ja eigentlich auch hoch veranlagt ist, ein Shaker ist aus Magdeburg gekommen, ein Bobzin und dann haben sie noch Elias Bethke festverpflichtet von Cottbus als Torhüter. Da sind sie ja auch immer wieder verletzungsgeplagt. Und jetzt gab es die Catmen in den Krisenduellen. 2 zu 0 gegen Fürth, 2 zu 1 ein Derby gegen Magdeburg beim ersten FC Magdeburg. Nur ein Gegenteuer in den zwei Spielen. Und das finde ich die größte Sensation der Pfortmann, den mich 34 in 17 erhalten. Also man agiert wesentlich stabiler, wesentlich cleverer. Matthias, wie blickst du auf diesen Start von Dresden? Hättest du dir den vorstellen können oder überrascht dich das jetzt sehr?
Den Sieg gegen Fürth vor heimischem Publikum, ich glaube, den konnte man einkalkulieren. Oder er kam jetzt für mich zumindest nicht aus dem heiteren Himmel. Der Sieg in Magdeburg gestern, der hat mich sehr überzeugt. Muss ich sagen, das war schon wirklich eine sehr reife Leistung. Und was Fürth quasi gar nicht erst herausgefordert hat, das hat dann Magdeburg zumindest in der ersten Halbzeit, im Laufe der Spielzeit schon. Also dann versucht auch Dresden zu beschäftigen und Premier dann auch im eigenen Drittel irgendwie zu fordern. Aber das hat Dresden nicht lange beunruhigt. Also sie haben da, finde ich, schon ihr Spiel mit einer gewissen Selbstverständlichkeit dann durchgezogen. Das hat mich wirklich überrascht und das war auch eine geschlossene Mannschaftsleistung. Du hast gerade schon einige Neuzugänge erwähnt, die quasi ohne viel Anlaufzeit sofort funktionieren. Also JK., finde ich, muss man auch erwähnen, hat dem Spiel so eine gewisse Note gegeben, die Doppel-Sechs mit Wagner Amuaku auch super unterwegs. Hat man ohnehin einen Dauerbrenner. Die Innenverteidigung mit Pauli und Keller auch stabil. Also da greift plötzlich sehr viel ineinander. Und ich finde es bemerkenswert, dass sie an den Trainer festhalten und der offenbar mit dem neuen Personal jetzt erst mal so eine Trennwende hinlegt. Es freut mich zum einen, weil es einfach auch zeigt, dass es nicht immer nur ein Trainerwechsel bedarf, um vielleicht dann noch mit ein bisschen Geduld was herbeizuführen, was davor gefehlt hat. Und ein wichtiger Faktor ist natürlich der neue Geschäftsführersport mit Sören Gonta, der da glaube ich erst mal sehr viel für den Moment richtig gemacht hat und das Team es sofort umsetzen kann. Also um deine Frage nochmal abzurunden, Fird, da hatte ich durchaus mit einem Erfolg gerechnet. Magdeburg hat es fett unterstrichen, aber kam für mich überraschend.
Das ist gesagt, sie sind den anderen Weg gegangen. Im November wurde Thomas Brändel freigestellt als sportlich Verantwortlicher. Und dann jetzt eben durch den Sets hat man sich da auf diesem Wege verändert, jetzt im Winter ordentlich zugeschlagen und vielleicht so auch das ermöglicht, was sich der Trainer vielleicht schon vorher gewünscht hatte. Denn ich fand schon die Sommertransferperiode, das hatte ich in der Prognose auch damals für die 2. Liga Vorschau gesagt, ich fand das sehr zurückhaltend. Daran gemessen, wie wenig 2. Liga-Erfahrungen der Kader ohnehin nach dem Aufstieg hatte. Weil dieser Kader ist nun mal lange in der 3. Liga gewesen. Und dafür hat man, finde ich, sehr wenig getan. Ich weiß nicht, ob man jetzt über gewisse Limits gegangen ist, ob man gesagt hat, nichts ist teurer als ein Abstieg und wir gehen jetzt vielleicht noch ein bisschen finanziell ins Risiko. Das kann ich nicht beurteilen, aber ich fand die Sommertransferperiode sehr, sehr konservativ. Und jetzt hat man vielleicht das getan, was man vielleicht damals schon hätte tun können bis müssen. Und vielleicht hat es dafür dann aber den richtigen sportlichen Verantwortlichen gebraucht, der da eher Hand in Hand mit dem geht, was der Trainer vielleicht auch möchte. Ich meine, Jonas Sterner, der war ja in der 3. Liga schon bei Dresden. Den hat man damals irgendwie nicht halten können. Er ist jetzt zurückgekehrt, weil es bei Hannover nicht gut lief. Also da gibt es viele Komponenten. Und ich meine, dass offensiv bei Dresden immer etwas geht, das war klar. Ich fand die in dieser Hinrunde selten offensiv abgemeldet. Es war eigentlich immer so, dass sie irgendwelche brauchbaren Aktionen hatten, jetzt eben auch über Standards. Und jetzt ist man zumindest wieder vollends dran an den Nicht-Abstiegsplätzen. Man ist zwar weiterhin 17. Aber eben drei Punkte vor viert und super nah dran an allem, was da ist, um da einmal kurz vielleicht auch den Kontext zu setzen, über den wir heute reden. Diese zweite Liga ist nach wie vor völlig bescheuert. Wir reden über den Platz 17, der 19 Punkte hat und über Platz, ich sage jetzt mal, ich rechne mal bis Platz 10 von mir aus, Holstein, Kiel, die 24 Punkte haben. Dazwischen haben wir 23, 21, 20, 20, 20, 20 Punkte. Also Düsseldorf, Münster, Magdeburg und Bielefeld haben allesamt dieselbe Punktzahl und Braunschweig hat nur ein Punkt mehr. Das wird in dieser Rückrunde wieder der Wahnsinn und dieser Satz in der zweiten Liga-Spiel zu entweder um den Aufstieg oder gegen den Abstieg geht mal wieder vollends und da ist zumindest Dresden jetzt wieder vollend der Verlosung und das ist, glaube ich, schon mal ein Erfolg, nachdem man in der Hinrunde so ein bisschen, ja, abgeschangen ist zu viel, aber so ein bisschen durchaus war, hatte ich das Gefühl. Nächstes Spiel ist übrigens gegen Bielefeld. Das ist das nächste Keller-Duell. Sollte Dresden dieses Spiel gewinnen, würden sie mit zwei Punkten vor Bielefeld stehen, die aktuell zumindest reintabellare Streitshinter sind. Wie gesagt, 2. Liga bescheuert. Und da ist jetzt Dresden wieder voll in der Verlosung. Kevin, wenn du zu Dynamo nicht mehr viel zu sagen hättest, würde ich dich beim nächsten Team reinholen. Matthias, meldet sich da unbedingt.
Ich hab noch einen Aspekt, genau, und zwar, was mir auch im Gegensatz zu den Spielen, zumindest im Dezember aufgefallen ist, dass offenbar Dresden noch mal ein bisschen eine Systemumstellung vorgenommen hat. Also davor 3-4-2-1, jetzt 4-2-3-1. Also das heißt, sie haben jetzt das Zentrum vielleicht ein bisschen mehr verdichtet, als es davor der Fall war. Ich hatte die Dezember-Spiele nicht so sehr im Blick, muss ich gestehen, aber zumindest ist das doch eine Auffälligkeit, dass sie mit den Personalien, die sie sich jetzt einfach geleistet haben, auch hier die Stellschrauben drehen und das scheint sehr gut zu fruchten. Und eben auch gestern mit dem Spiel in Magdeburg, wo ich glaube, dass sie es einfach verstanden haben, nicht nervös zu werden. Also sie verteidigen geschlossen, aber haben sich nicht verbarrikadiert. Und sie sind auch im letzten Drittel von Magdeburg ziemlich aggressiv angelaufen. Auch zum Schluss gab es noch eine Phase, wo sie das getan hatten. Also das nötigt mir Respekt ab, Schapro. Und damit kommen wir zum nächsten Team.
Sehr gerne, sehr gerne. Das nächste Team ist der KSC. Das war uns beiden wichtig, Matthias, dass wir diesen Verein hier mit dabei haben. Und ich würde Kevin gleich dazu holen, weil er die Notwendigkeit gar nicht so gesehen hat. Und das finde ich ja mal kontroversen, sind auch auch mal nett im Rasenfunk. Muss doch nicht immer nur hier Harmonie sein. Können auch mal streiten. Nein. Erst mal, apropos Streit. Das ist eigentlich eine sehr gute Überleitung, die ich mir selber gebaut habe, denn der KSC hat wirklich Horrorwochen hinter sich. Wir haben das plötzliche, wie auch sehr chaotische, zumindest chaotisch kommunizierte Aus von Co-Trainer Zlatan Bajamović, einsichtlich gebrochener Christian Eichner. Wir haben das mehr als unangemessene Verhalten oder zumindest die Äußerung von Vizepräsident Uwe Meisch im Trainingslager. Ich kann das Ganze jetzt hier nicht komplett aufmachen, das wird den Rahmen sprengen. Ihr findet dazu genug Artikel, auf jeden Fall online. Und dazu eben vom 12. bis inklusive 16. Spieltag fünf Niederlagen am Stück. Und man musste wirklich um den KSC fürchten. Man musste sich Sorgen machen, ob das jetzt komplett einbricht. Aber die Karlsruher, zumindest die Mannschaft und Trainer, haben darauf eine Antwort gefunden. Denn es gab jetzt zunächst ein 2-0-Sieg in Münster und dann jetzt ein 2-2 gegen Hertha. Das heißt, vier Punkte aus den zwei Spielen. Wenn man das Spiel vor der Winterpause dazu nimmt gegen Bochum, ist man seit drei Spielen immerhin umgeschlagen und zeigt, dass man zumindest wieder da ist. Christian Eichner arbeitet scheinbar unbeirrt weiter und stabilisiert seine Truppe mit natürlich Mavi Vanicek Hand in Hand, der gegen Münster mal wieder extremst wichtig war, die beiden Tore erzielt hat. Aber eben auch durch die Rückkehr vieler Spieler. Also Christian Eichner hatte diesen Satz gesagt, die Unterschiedsspieler beim KSC sind zurück. Oder meint der Spieler wie Louis-Ben Fahad, wie ein Eklopf. Gleichzeitig gibt es weiterhin Defensivprobleme. Aber Kevin, du hast gar nicht so die Notwendigkeit gesehen, heute über den KSC zu reden. Kannst du das einmal ausführen? Das ist ja interessant.
Wahrscheinlich einmal, wenn sie auf Platz 8 stehen, wobei natürlich auch da alles eng beieinander ist. Du hast ja auch von Platz 1 bis, keine Ahnung, wo sieben Punkte dazwischen nur, da bedarf es zwei, drei Spiele. Und dann sieht das auch schon ganz anders aus.
Du sagst, lass die mal die vier Punkte nicht holen, dann sind die knietief drin, ne?
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Aber man muss auch sagen, gegen Hertha haben sie sie gerade so irgendwie geholt, weil Hertha drückend, in meiner Ansicht nach, schon drückend überlegen war. Sie haben sich erkämpft. Das ist natürlich ein gutes Prädikat, gerade im Mittelfeld der Zweitligisten. Und wie du sagst, mit einer Tendenz nach unten, wo du den Kampf annimmst. Das ist auf jeden Fall geschehen, gerade nach diesen wilden Wochen um das Team herum, die sicherlich keinen Spaß gemacht haben, weder den Spielern noch vor allem auch dem Trainerteam. Sie haben mit Ambrosius sicherlich einen wichtigen Spieler von Elversberg dazugeholt, der vielleicht noch mal in so ein bisschen...
Elversberg?
Oder nicht von Elversberg?
Der kam aus der Schweiz.
Aus der Schweiz St. Gallen, glaube ich.
Hm, glaube ich auch. Aber auf jeden Fall war es notwendig, ihn zu verpflichten, weil Beifuß eben mit Knorpelschaden ausfällt. Also mussten sie nachlegen und...
Ja, ist auf jeden Fall ein Stabilitätsfaktor, finde ich direkt. Haben sie nötig. KSC geht viel über Stabilität. Man sieht, sie haben ja immer noch minus 6 Tore in der Torabilanz. Das heißt, wenn sie verlieren, dann hoch. Wenn sie gewinnen, dann knapp und eng, mit viel Kampf. Und ja, ich verstehe schon, warum ihr sie drin haben wolltet. Aber ja, 2-0 Auswärtssieg in Münster ist jetzt auch nicht das, weswegen mich es als KSC für den Euphorie verfallen lassen würde. Und zweitseits auch gegen Hertha. Wie gesagt, Hertha fand ich stärker. Also ich sehe beim KSC nicht die Entwicklung spielerisch, dass sie irgendwie jetzt einen Riesenschritt gemacht hätten. Auch wenn vier Punkte natürlich wichtig und richtig sind in der Situation. Aber aus dem Gesichtspunkt hin, da hat sich was getan in der Winterpause. Da sehe ich das nicht.
Also wir hatten ja schon mal Mitte November über den KSC gesprochen. Da waren sie noch mit in dem Gruppetto, das so mit nach vorne blicken durfte. Und da hatten wir sie schon ein bisschen rausgerechnet, weil sie einfach ich glaube damals auch 4-0 in Bielefeld verloren hatten. Das war sehr frisch der Eindruck. Aber auch ansonsten waren sie auswärts einfach nicht auf der Höhe, um ein mögliches Spitzenteam darzustellen. Der Kader erscheint immer noch sehr dünn, also vergleichsweise dünn. Und deshalb war es wahrscheinlich umso wertvoller, dass jetzt die von dir genannten Unterschiedsspieler wieder an Bord sind. Und das kann vielleicht auch dazu führen, dass so jemand wie Förster, der in der Hinode jetzt sehr später verpflichtet wurde und auch in Darmstadt eine Vergangenheit hat, der dann nicht so wirklich überzeugen konnte. Ich glaube, er ist jemand, der dann in einem funktionierenden Angriffsspiel mit Leuten neben und um ihn rum, die auch was drauf haben, auf gut Deutsch, der vielleicht noch ein bisschen heller strahlen kann und dem Spiel dann auch ein bisschen mehr Impulse geben kann, als es lange getan hat. Und wir waren nachher noch über ihn zu reden.
Dann kriege ich mal kurz rein zu Förster, weil ich ihn ja jetzt gegen Hertha auch gesehen habe. Da hat er zum Beispiel einen wunderbaren Abschluss, der gegen den Außenpfosten geht. Also der ist schon im 1 gegen 1. Das denkt man bei ihm so gar nicht, weil er nicht so aussieht, fände ich. Aber der ist technisch schon richtig gut. Und der, wie du sagst, wenn dann er in einem Dreieck mit einem Bonic und einem Jungen agieren darf, zu seinen Momenten kommt und auch dem Gegner, wie Hertha wehtun kann.
Ja, also er wirkt so manchmal ein bisschen phlegmatisch auf dem Spielfeld. Er ist aber auf jeden Fall einer, der mit Auge und Technik viel, viel beitragen kann. Nimmt sich aber eben manchmal auch Spiele, wo man ihn kaum wahrnimmt. Nichtsdestotrotz, um den KSC vielleicht auch abzuschließen. Also wir hatten Münster das Spiel erwähnt, als sie 2-0 gewonnen hatten. Da war Bernhard dem Tor ein ganz wesentlicher Faktor. Wir werden nachher noch über Münster reden. Da hat er sie im Spiel gehalten. Zum Schluss haben sie dann von einem Platzverweis profitiert. Aber das war einfach wichtig, um nicht weiter den Rückspiegel in Blick nehmen zu müssen. Und diese Niederlagen-Serie, diese Bilanz des Grauens von fünf Niederlagen in Serie konnte ja auch mit den ganzen Rahmengeschichten, die du genannt hast, schon zu Schlimmerem führen. Und deshalb würde ich mal sagen, die Bremse rein zu hauen, war schon mal ganz gut. Und gestern ging Hertha dann 2 zu 2 zu ziehen. Gleich wollte sie sich viel erwehren zu müssen. Aber dennoch einen Punkt mitzunehmen, ist ja auch nochmal was, was sie sich auf ihre Habenzeiten schreiben können. Und ein letzter Aspekt, der auch so ein bisschen rund um den KSC rumwabert, war ja auch so eine Aussage des Geschäftsführers Michael Becker, der irgendwie Irritationen hervorgerufen hat, bezüglich der Kosten für den Stadionumbau. Als er davon sprach, es wären 210 Millionen und die Stadt sagt, es waren 155 Millionen und die Stadt zahlt ja die Zeche unter KSC, aber die Pacht. Und die Pacht hat sich wohl auch noch verringert. Also das sorgt wohl in, in Stuttgart sage ich schon, pardon, in Karlsruhe auch so in der Stadtpolitik und im Stadtgeschehen für ein bisschen Irritationen, wie denn so unterschiedliche Zahlen ins Spiel kommen. Und wer sagt denn hier die Wahrheit? Und das ist ja für jede Kommune nicht gerade unwesentlich, ob wir hier über eine Differenz von 65 Millionen sprechen, also oder 55. Das ist schon komisch, was der KSC da manchmal so in seiner Außendarstellung fabriziert.
Absolut. Und das ist für mich irgendwie auch der Kontext dessen, warum ich sie hier dabei haben wollte, weil ja, es sind an sich nicht die berühmtesten Leistungen jetzt gewesen. Das, da würde ich mit Kevin auch mitgehen. Das ist jetzt strahlend nicht hell und spektakulär. Aber es hätte so viel schlechter aussehen können nach den letzten Wochen vor dem Jahresende. Und wie gesagt, wenn diese Form weitergegangen wäre, wenn sie jetzt wieder zwei Spiele verloren hätten, dann wären die mittendrin, hätten irgendwie seit gefühlt acht Spielen kein Spiel mehr gewonnen. Und dann will ich mal sehen, wie es da weitergeht auch um Christian Eichner und Co., der vielleicht auch irgendwann entnervt, sagt, Freunde, ich will hier meine Arbeit machen, aber so viele Baustellen haben hier die Atmosphäre komplett zerstört. Das funktioniert nicht mehr. Und da, wie Matthias Treffen gesagt hat, die Bremse reingehauen haben zu können, ist, glaube ich, sehr viel wert. Und das wird diese Saison wieder nur um den Tassenhalt gehen. Aber in dieser Saison mehr denn je habe ich das Gefühl. Und das wird mehr denn je ein Erfolg für den KSC sein. Und dann gucken wir mal, wie es weitergeht. Aber Stand jetzt sind diese vier Punkte aus zwei Spielen sehr wichtig. Zumal jetzt dann ja Spiele schon mit noch ein bisschen Druck auf dem Kessel anstehen, denn man spielt als Nächstes in Braunschweig und danach gegen Düsseldorf. So und da kann man glaube ich mit den vier Punkten im Kreuz sagen, wenn wir da eher zwei Punkte holen, ist jetzt auch okay, dann halten wir sie zumindest auf Abstand. Das ist ja auch fürs Mindset der Spieler vielleicht gar nicht so schlecht. So und ich würde sagen, dann reden wir über das nächste Team. Das ist der 1. FC Karlerslautern. Matthias, möchtest du da einmal ausholen? Sie haben jetzt 3 zu 1 gegen Hannover gewonnen, jetzt ein 2 zu 2 auf Schalke, sehr spät erst kassiert, sahen ja auch da lange wieder Gewinner aus. Wie, welchen Eindruck machen die auf dich nach der Winterpause?
Ja, einen erstaunlich guten. Also gegen Hannover 3 zu 1 zu gewinnen, da hatte ich so leichte Darmstadt-Erinnerungen. Also sprich Hannover gegen in Führung und dann kam irgendwann die Wucht des FCK natürlich noch ein bisschen mit, profitiert von einem Platzverweis für Hannover, der ein bisschen dämlich war. Aber nun denn, da hat Kaislautern die Chance ergriffen, hat das Spiel gedreht, 3 zu 1 gewonnen. Und heute war ich primär gespannt, wie sie auswärts auftreten, weil das doch so ein bisschen die Arillisferse des FCK ist. Da haben sie vor dem Spiel, meine ich, bislang erst acht Punkte geholt, jetzt sind es dann eben neun. Und vielleicht haben die ein oder anderen von uns noch den Auftritt in Bielefeld vor Augen, wo Kais Lauthorn quasi Anti-Fußball gespielt hat. Und sich von Anfang an nur mit dem Willen, einen Punkt mitzunehmen, da ja so angetreten ist und den er auch gezogen hat. Aber es war für ein Team, das eher nach oben schielt, ernüchternd bis erschreckend damals, die Performance. Und deshalb war ich gespannt, ob sie da heute eh nicht agieren, aber sie haben es anders gemacht. Also sie haben so ein bisschen den Ansatz gefahren, Safety First, aber sie sind sehr schnell ausgeschwärmt. Also sie hatten mit Ritzas, Gütey und Bassett, der neu gekommen ist zur Winterpause, dann den schnellen, direkten Weg nach vorne gesucht. Und das hat lange nicht gefruchtet, aber dennoch haben sie Schalke beschäftigen können. Und dann gibt es so jemanden wie Briteien, den sie von der Bank bringen können, der dann auch noch prompt mit seiner quasi Eingabe den 1 zu 0 Treffer macht und dann auch noch super stark den Konter zu Ende fährt, zum 2 zu 0. Was zeigt, die haben sich eine Taktik zurechtgelegt, die funktioniert. Also sie haben erst mal hinten versucht, nicht sonderlich viel anbrennen zu lassen und dann sehr zielgerichtet nach vorne zu spielen oder eben auch mal so ein Standard zu nutzen. Und es hätte ja fast zu einem Dreier geführt, aber dann gab es eben so ein Betze-Moment in umgekehrter Form, nämlich dass auch Schalke daheim gerne mal einen Rückstand zumindest egalisieren kann. Also das fand ich schon bemerkenswert abgezockt, könnte man sagen, wie laut und aufgetreten ist. Und was man eben auch sieht, sie können inzwischen auf einen breiteren Kader setzen. Also wer von der Bank, Parteien, Schahin und Hans Lig bringen kann, das wäre wahrscheinlich in der Vorrunde nicht immer gegangen, weil sie doch immer mal wieder Lücken im Kader hatten. Oder eben Leute, die das Niveau nicht so wirklich halten können. Und deshalb ist es vielleicht auch ein kleiner Faktor, dass sie jetzt gerade viele an Bord haben, die dann auch wiederum Optionen sind, im Spielverlauf ihren Stempel zu hinterlassen oder ihren Eindruck zu machen auf das Team und auf den Spielverlauf. Und jetzt spielen sie als nächstes gegen Elbersberg und in der Amstatt. Also sie haben weiter die Gelegenheit, Boden gut zu machen gegen direkte Kontrahenten. Und ganz weit geblickt, das Ende der Saison sind dann eher gegen vermeintlich leichtere Gegner. Zumindest Braunschweig, Dresden, Bielefeld, Magdeburg. Wenn die im Abstiegskampf stehen, ist das kein Selbstläufer. Aber zumindest haben sie erst mal die Big Fish am Anfang der Rückrunde. Also mal gucken, was da sich so entwickelt. Und mich haben sie wirklich sehr überrascht. Gleichwohl, ein Jamfie hat auch gemerkt zum Schluss, ein Dzeko ist nicht Gommis. Den konnte er locker abkochen zwei, dreimal in der ersten Halbzeit. Dzeko blieb standhaft und hat den Anschlusstreffer gemacht.
Ja, ja, ich kann die Taktik von Karsten Sartor auf jeden Fall verstehen zu sagen, zu Hause setzen wir auf den Betze-Bonus. Ist ja auch einfach. Also es funktioniert ja so, das ist ja kein bangen und hoffen, sondern es funktioniert ja wirklich da, so eine Wucht zu entwickeln. Und auswärts werden wir richtig humorlos sein. Gegen Bielefeld fand ich tatsächlich fast ein bisschen unwürdig dieses Spiel. Aber auf Schalke zu sagen, ey, soll Schalke doch erst mal machen mit dem Ball? Gucken wir mal. Und zur Not sind wir da über Konter- oder Standard-Situationen. Das finde ich jetzt in Ordnung. Also wenn sich Thorsten Dieberknecht vor dem Spiel hinstellt und sagt, ey, ganz ehrlich, eine Scheißleistung und drei Punkte gegen Schalke nehme ich, das kann ich irgendwo verstehen von der Herangehensweise her, weil alte Regel gewinnt sie jedes Heimspiel, spielt jedes Aussaatsspiel unentschieden, dann wirst du wahrscheinlich aufsteigen. Und dementsprechend ist das besonders gegen die Top-Teams natürlich ein legitimer Ansatz. Du hast es schon erwähnt. Norman Bassett haben sie sich nach vorne geholt. Der vielleicht noch ohne Tor da steht. Der aber ermöglicht durch seine reine Präsenz, dass ein Ivan Pratayan von der Bank kommen kann. Der nun mal aktuell körperlich noch nicht bei 100% ist, bei weitem nicht. Der aber dann seine entscheidenden Momente bekommt. Und jetzt in den beiden Spielen nach der Rückrunde oder nach dem Rückrundstart so schon wieder bei 3 Toren steht. Insgesamt übrigens bei 11, was gemessen in seiner Spielzeit lächerlich ist. Also es ist eine absurde Quote. Und hinten hat jetzt beispielsweise ja auch ein neuer gespielt. Athanas Scherneff, richtig bulliger Innenverteidiger, Bulgare, 1,95 groß, yo. Also das ist auch Zweitligamaterial, der da auch wieder ermöglicht, dass ein Jan Elvedi, der in der Hinrunde wirklich oft nicht gut aussah, da mal auf der Bank sitzen kann. Also man schafft sich so ein paar Möglichkeiten. Könnte sogar vorstellen, dass es vielleicht nicht die letzten Transfers sind. Sollte da Geld übrig sein, weil es gibt noch andere Problemzonen. Per se aber so schon mal ein runderer Kader mit einem okayen Ansatz. Ich bleibe aber kritisch und sage, man ist weiterhin sehr abhängig von Ivan Britein. Also sehr abhängig, ungesund abhängig, würde ich fast sagen. Man ist weiter, finde ich, im Spiel relativ eindimensional. Besonders, wenn Skewtick keinen fantastischen Tag erwischt, dann wird es kreativ extremst dünn. Ich glaube weiterhin nicht daran, dass Lautern letztendlich aufsteigen wird. Ich habe schon in der Vorschau gesagt, für mich ist es auf jeden Fall ein Top-7-Team. Also da gibt es gar keine Diskussion. Aber dann in die ersten drei zu kommen, besonders in die ersten zwei, das sehe ich nicht. Dafür werden sie zu viele Spiele, glaube ich, so ein bisschen zäh liegen lassen. Aber das ist ja okay und für den Start ist das jetzt wirklich sehr in Ordnung gewesen. Deswegen ist es vollkommen verdient bei Spielen gegen Hannover und Schalke, das muss man ja nochmal sagen, als Kontext vier Punkte zu holen, ist absolut verdient, dann hier genannt zu werden. Trotzdem bin ich skeptisch, was den weiteren Blick angeht. Kevin, wie würdest du die Schaumung des FCK…
Geht mir genauso, wenn ich da nochmal kurz einkrätschen darf. Also sehe ich genauso, auch da hat sich an meine Meinung von November wenig geändert. Da hatte ich auch schon gesagt, dass das am Ende wahrscheinlich zu wenig sein wird. Allerdings, wir kennen lieber Knecht. Er hat mit Underdog-Teams durchaus auch mit Braunschweig und Nachschluss den Aufstieg geschafft. Das ist ihm auch in Lautern zuzutrauen. Und er ist einfach ein pragmatischer Charakter. Also er versucht dann aus einer Mannschaft jetzt nicht, irgendwas herauf zu beschweren, was gar nicht drin steckt. Und das ist vielleicht mit einem Faustpfand jetzt für die nächsten Wochen und Monate. Aber ich glaube auch noch nicht so recht dran, dass da wirklich zum Schluss noch Lautern in der Verlosung ist. Aber jetzt gerne Kevin.
Da muss ich mich erst mal imuten. Ja, Casus Lauter und ich sind sowieso immer ein zwiegespaltenes Thema. Ich finde beachtlich, dass sie immer wieder in den letzten Jahren gute Stürmer entdecken, die ihnen helfen mit Ragnar Ache oder jetzt halt Britalien. Das ist schon– gerade in der 2. Liga, finde ich, ein enormes Faustpfand und bin aber gleichzeitig bei euch, dass das halt auch der Grund ist, warum sie gerade mit oben in der Verlosung sind und warum sie dann aber auch aus meiner Sicht den entscheidenden Schritt wahrscheinlich nicht machen werden am Ende. Weil so etwas fehlt, wie jetzt auf Schalke, das Spiel dann einzusacken. Ja, also das ist schon beachtlich gegen die direkten Konkurrenten, die da oben stehen, vier Punkte zu holen, alles cool. Jetzt kommen, du hast ja schon gesagt, Matthias, zwei weitere starke Gegner mit Elbersberg und dann halt Darmstadt. Ich meine, das ist schon ein ordentliches Programm in die Rückrunde. Und ich bin halt jetzt gespannt, was diese späte Schalke-Ausgleich, also diese Auffalljagd mit Kaiserslautern macht. Weil ich meine, wenn die mit einem 2-0-Von Schalke nach Hause fahren, dann haben sie, glaube ich, ein richtiges Momentum. Jetzt ärgern sie sich, glaube ich, maßlos, dass sie das so hergeschenkt haben noch oder zwei Punkte halt verloren haben. Bin echt gespannt. Aber wie gesagt, also sie haben halt einfach diese Stürmer als Riesenbonus. Auch im Vergleich zu anderen Mitkonkurrenten. Also wenn man jetzt Paderborn zum Beispiel sieht, die eher Probleme haben, Stürmer zu finden, der da vorne regelmäßig Tore schießt. Also es sind ja noch andere, die oben in der Verlosung mit sind, die dieses Problem haben. Das könnte, je nachdem, wenn Lieber, wenn ich das hinkriege, diese Aussetzer, nenn ich es mal, in den Griff zu kriegen, dann könnten sie trotzdem bis zum Ende oben mit dran bleiben. Und dann haben sie natürlich das vermeintlich leichteste Restprogramm von den Teams da oben. Aber ich traue den Braten auch nicht so richtig.
Das Interessante ist, dass wir ja eher bei Kreiserslautern die Spiele gegen die Teams von unten Sorgen machen, weil Ballbesitzspielen nicht die Stärke von Thorsten Lieberknecht ist und sie sich genau in diesen Spielen oft die Zähne ausbeißen, weil der Gegner sagt, naja, kommt doch. So, wir verteidigen einfach die Tiefe. Versucht doch mal dann mit euren Schienenspielern durchzubrechen und irgendeine gescheite Flanke auf verteilen zu bringen. Die kommt da gar nicht erst hin. Das sind eher die Spiele, wo ich das Gefühl habe, dass sich die Lauterer die Zähne ausbeißen. Diese offeneren Duelle, wo sie kontern können, wo sie Platz haben. Das sind dann die Spiele, die interessant für sie sind.
Ja, und sie hatten, glaube ich, jetzt vor dem Spiel gegen Schalke fünf Spiele davor, zwölf Gegentore kassiert, jetzt wieder zwei. Sie müssen also extrem viele Tore auch schießen, um dann ein Spiel zu gewinnen. Was natürlich auch ein immenser Kraftakt ist, den du auch erst mal über so eine ganze Serie hinkriegen musst. Also ich glaube, sie sind defensiv nicht gut genug aufgestellt, um letztendlich ganz oben zu landen.
Die Prognose nehmen wir doch mal so mit und wandern. Dementsprechend jetzt noch zu einem letzten Team, das wir kurz besprechen wollen, wenn wir schon mal den Experten da haben. Matthias, die Darmstädter, sie sind nicht von oben wegzubekommen. Im Gegenteil, sie beißen sich regelrecht fest und haben den Abstand auf Schalke jetzt auf zwei Punkte schmelzen lassen. Lassen wir noch mal kurz gucken. Das waren jetzt die Spiele 3-3 gegen Bochum und das 2-0 gegen Nürnberg. Jetzt ist man seit neun Spielen ohne Liederlage. Die letzte Nullnummer stammt vom 24. Oktober. Das war übrigens das 0-1 gegen Schalke. Also wenn das Spiel unentschieden ausgeht, dann ist es lustigerweise dann jetzt auch gerade zwei Punkte, die sie trennen. Wie blickst du gerade auf deine Lilien? Wie blickst du auf diesen Rückrundenstart?
Glück, würde ich sagen. Also in Bochum einen Punkt mitzunehmen, da darf man einverstanden sein, weil gerade ist halt Rösler da an der Seitenlinie steht bei Bochum. Da sind sie auch schwer zu besiegen. Und es war ein wildes Spiel, für meinen Begriff etwas zu wild. Kevin wird sich auch noch an das letzte Spiel vor der Winterpause erinnern, 2-2 in Paderborn. Da hatte Darmstadt 2-0 geführt und hat dann noch zwei Eier gefangen. Also das ist vielleicht auch so was, was mir im Hinblick auf Auswärtsspiele ein bisschen Sorgen bereitet. Und das nächste Auswärtsspiel steht ja jetzt am Wochenende bei Hertha an, dass sie sowohl in Paderborn als auch in Bochum im Laufe der zweiten Halbzeit nicht mehr wirklich aktiv waren. Also sie haben sich zu sehr in die Defensive fallen lassen, hatten nicht mehr die Spielanteile wie noch in der ersten Halbzeit. Und das war jetzt nicht zwingend in der Luft gelegen, in Bochum dann noch den dritten Treffer und damit den Ausgleich zu kassieren. In Paderborn gleich wohl schon. Also da war es für mich klar, da kannst du die Uhr danach stellen. Irgendwann geht es eben unentschieden aus. Und da waren sie auch im Nachhinein sehr kritisch. Also auch Kohfeldt und die Spieler, dass sie so nicht das Spiel zu Ende spielen wollten. Aber sie konnten offenbar in dem Moment nicht anders als das über sich ergehen lassen. Und da müssen sie schleunigst die richtigen Schlüsse draus ziehen. Aber wie auch immer, sie haben erst zwei Niederlagen im gesamten Saisonverlauf. Das heißt, es ist eine gewisse Stabilität da. Kofel sagte auch nach dem Spiel gegen Nürnberg, selbst wenn der Plan, den sie sich zurechtgelegt haben, nicht funktioniert, die Mannschaft wird nicht unruhig. Sie findet Wege ins Spiel zu kommen und dann auch Torabschlüsse zu generieren und auf genug Tore zu schießen. Sie sind jetzt mit, ich glaube, Kaiserslautern und Elbersberg, die treffen sich aus der Offensive. Und das gibt mir gleich wohl wieder ein bisschen Zuversicht. Also sie finden es immer wieder doch zurück ins Spiel und wissen dann auch nach vorne ihre Chancen oft genug zu nutzen. Und deshalb, gegen Nürnberg lief auch nicht von Anfang an alles in die Richtung der Lilien, aber sie schaffen es dann einfach auch, den Gegnern nicht jetzt nur rechts und links zur Seite zu stehen und zu sagen, bitte marschier durch und mach das Tor, sondern sie erwähnen sich. Aber so ein richtiges Spitzen-Team bin ich mir nicht immer sicher, ob sie das tatsächlich sind, auch wenn sie gerade Zweiter sind. Aber so richtig traue ich dem ganzen Braten tatsächlich nicht. Marc überraschend klingen bei so einer stabilen Tabellensituation und auch den letzten Ergebnissen. Aber ich weiß nicht, wie seht ihr das als Außenstehende? Ich bin da noch so ein bisschen im Wasserstand.
Also ich finde sie, wenn ich dazu sagen darf, ich finde sie halt unspektakulär. Und das ist einfach das, was sie von Schalke zum Beispiel mit dem ganzen Primorium drum herum unterscheidet. Oder Kaiserslautern mit diesem Betze, der dann immer bäbt oder keine Ahnung was. Aber sie machen eine Souveränheit, sie strahlen Souverität aus über die ganze Saison. Vor allem natürlich auch zu Hause. Ich glaube Saison übergreifend, ungeschlagen zu Hause. Und in den letzten sechs Spielen nimmt sie vier Siege, zwei Unentschieden. Also, sie fahren halt regelmäßig die Punkte ein und ich finde auch sehr, sehr souverän. Also das, was Florian Kohfeldt, das habe ich mir zu Darmstadt aufgeschrieben, geschafft hat, ist so ein bisschen diese, der hat halt die Defensive stabilisiert, aber nicht gleichzeitig Offensivkraft geopfert dafür. Also er hat das halt mit der Mannschaft, finde ich, sehr gut hinbekommen, dass sie beides kann und auch weiß, wann sie es anwenden muss, in welcher Intensität. Das finde ich hat Darmstadt einen großen Vorteil, zum Beispiel gegenüber Schalke. Schalke fährt sehr viele Unentschieden ein, weil sie halt diese Stabilität und diese Balance nicht immer hinkriegen und im falschen Moment dann halt das Tor kassieren. Und Darmstadt kriegt es halt echt hin, den Kasten dann auch mal dicht zu machen. Also ein 1-0 über die Zeit zu bringen. Oder einfach über die Zeit, übrigens vielleicht falsch formuliert, aber du weißt, was ich meine wahrscheinlich. Ich finde, sie sind reifer als Schalke 04. Aber sie sind unspektakulärer. Auch vom Personal her, von den Namen her. Das ist auch gar nicht schlimm, finde ich. Das war immer schon ein Vorteil, den Darmstadt hatte, finde ich. Um ihnen zu nahe treten zu wollen, sie spielen sich auch in ihrer Außendarstellung, nicht in den Vordergrund, sondern sie machen das auf dem Platz, sportlich. Und das, finde ich, strahlt eine Ruhe aus. Und wie ich gesagt habe, Souveränität, die zum Beispiel auch ein Riesenunterschied zu Kaiserslautern ist. Da wird verbal rausgehauen einer, da wird hier dies und das gemacht. Das ist eine ganz andere Mentalität. Also Momentum meiner Ansicht nach liegt momentan im Aufstiegskampf, im Aufstiegsrennen ganz klar bei Darmstadt.
Finde ich spannend. Also ich glaube, also in der Außendarstellung würde ich schon mitgehen. Das, was verbalisiert wird und ähnliches, das würde ich auch sagen, dass es eher still und professionell was Darmstadt da tut. Auf dem Feld wiederum finde ich sie durchaus spektakulär, weil ich finde, dass sie von der Offensive– sagt was gerne?
Ich meinte ja, also sie sind auf dem Platz, sind sie absolut Souveränität, sie sind offensiv stark, sind auch defensiv stark, sie haben eigentlich Best of Both Worlds in sich vereint. Bin ich bei dir, ne? Also schon, die spielen auch einen guten Fußball. Also als sie in Paderborn gespielt haben, du hast gesehen, was sie können, warum sie da stehen. Und ich finde, sie haben auch den richtigen Trainer dazu gewonnen. Ich finde es auch stark, dass sie das mit dem den Weg so gehen. Absolut beeindruckend. Also ich war nie ein großer Darmstadt-Sympathisant oder auch nicht gegen Darmstadt, sondern es war immer so für mich aus Paderborn heraus, wie für viele andere Paderborn auch, ist eine grauere Erscheinung. Aber das ist gar nicht bös gemeint. Ich finde, das macht Darmstadt aus. Sie machen sehr, sehr viel aus ihren Möglichkeiten. Und wie du sagst, sie haben tolle Spiele dabei, wo du sagst, sie spielen richtig guten Fußball. Sie haben aber auch wiederum Spiele dabei, wo sie selber merken, okay, heute ist nicht so unser Tag, aber dann machen wir es halt über den defensiven Aspekt und holen die Punkte.
Also da will ich auf jeden Fall mitgehen, diese Variabilität im Spielansatz ist definitiv da. Das sieht man ja auch dadurch, wie sie zwischen Dreier- und Viererkette wechseln können und das auf den Gegner abstimmen. Das ist ja schon fast ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal in dieser Liga, wie Variabelmann da ist. Und vor allen Dingen, das habe ich schon öfter gesagt, Florian Kohfeldt schafft das halt und das glaube ich, das wird sie bis zum Ende auch irgendwo tragen. Ob das dann für den Aufstieg reicht, sei mal dahingestellt, aber ich glaube, deswegen werden sie nicht mehr maßlos einbrechen. Er schafft das halt konzeptionell, Räume zu schaffen, Spielsituation zu schaffen, in denen die Offensivspieler glänzen können, und zwar alle. Klar wird sehr viel über Liedberg geredet, aber wenn wir dann mal gucken, denn Fraser Hornby steht bei 10 direkten Torbeteiligungen, Marco Richter bei 9, Kylian Corredor bei 7, Marseiler findet jetzt auch manchmal seine Momente. Also du hast so viele Offensivspieler, die dahingehend einen Unterschied ausmachen können, dass sich der Gegner auch nicht unbedingt nur auf Liedberg konzentrieren darf, weil dann kommen halt andere. Ich mag das Zusammenspiel zwischen den offensiven Außen und defensiven Außen, also wie da überlaufen wird. Also das Lope ist ja sehr, sehr gut drin und Marco Richter und Marseiler sind eher Spieler, die gerne auch mal nach innen ziehen. Also da ist eine Variabilität in diesem 4-4-2 drin, die ich beeindruckend finde. Spannend ist, dass von der Bank, ehrlich gesagt, nicht viel kommt. Also da bin ich manchmal schon gespannt, wenn jetzt zwei Spieler aus der Offensive gleichzeitig ausfallen würden, wie fängt man das auf? Weil Finn Lakenmacher, Semmy Güller und Boizis und Co. machen diese Saison wenig Dampf von der Bank. Korrigiere mich da gerne, Matthias, wenn du das anbefielst. Also da ist so ein bisschen die Frage, halten diese Spieler das durch, auch einfach körperlich, oder fallen dann mal ein, zwei Spieler aus, dann wird es, glaube ich, einfach von der individuellen Klasse her schwierig. Deswegen hat man jetzt auch ein Niklas Schmidt dazugeholt, wobei der jetzt auch lange nicht viel Fußball gespielt hat, aber von der Klasse her passt das wiederum. Und das ist auch ein Spieler, der Co-Feld schon kennt. Also ich will sagen, ich sehe sehr, sehr viel Gutes in Darmstadt. Das einzige Fragezeichen sehe ich in der Kaderbreite. Alles andere überzeugt mich dahingehend zu sagen, die werden bis zum Ende um die ersten drei Plätze mitspielen.
Also was ich noch hinzufügen kann, diese Variabilität, die hat sich auch gegen Nürnberg gezeigt. Also Hornby war lange Zeit kein Faktor in dem Spiel, hat regelrecht schlecht ausgesehen für seine Verhältnisse, wurde dann in der zweiten Halbzeit zu einem Zehner umfunktioniert und da hat er sehr viel mehr Spielanteile bekommen, Sicherheit gewonnen.
Schottische Voltemade.
Ja, so ein bisschen vielleicht. Würde mich sogar super freuen, aber ich glaube, das ist zu weit weg, um real zu sein. Wenn er noch auf den WM-Zug aufspringen würde mit Schottland, das würde ihm sehr viel bedeuten. Also sprich, er war dann in einer anderen Position auf dem Feld und konnte dem Spiel mehr geben. Akiyama rückte ein bisschen weiter nach vorne. Das heißt, dann hatte man da auch die Pasta-Fetten von Nürnberg ein bisschen besser im Zugriff. Und Marseille und Richter haben die Seiten getauscht, sind aber, wenn man das Spielfeld betrachtet, auf der Seite geblieben, wenn das auch in der ersten Halbzeit war. Und einen Ausfall wie Corridor, den konnten sie verkraften. Hornby war auch länger mal nicht dabei, konnten sie auch verkraften. Also einen von denen vorne kein Problem. Zwei würde womöglich schon ein bisschen schwerer ins Kontor schlagen. Aber sie haben dieses Jahr einfach auch eine stabile Achse, also Clefisch Akiyama als Doppel-Sechs ist gesetzt. Pfeiffer in der Innenverteidigung ist eine Bank und egal ob mit Magliza oder mit Vukotic neben ihm. Und vorne hat man halt die torgefährlicheren Spieler. Das heißt, da ist eine Achse, die letztes Jahr erst wachsen musste, die ist jetzt diese Saison da und damit auch ein Faktor, warum sie so da stehen, wie sie da stehen. Was mir aber auch so ein bisschen aufgefallen ist, in sechs der neuen letzten Spiele haben sie jeweils zwei oder sogar drei Gegentore gekriegt und das war zu viel. Das wird jemandem wie Schuhl nicht schmecken, auch jemandem wie Kohfeldt nicht schmecken. Da werden sie verstärkt ein Auge drauf richten müssen, dass da eben wieder mehr Stabilität in der Defensive in letzter Konsequenz ist. Hat jetzt nicht zugeführt, dass sie die Spiele verloren haben. Das ist ja auch schon eine Qualität, aber gleichwohl, das darf ein bisschen besser werden. Und mit Kohfeldt und Paul Fernie als sportlicher Leiter, da haben sie auch zwei an den verantwortlichen Stellen, die sich, glaube ich, auch sehr grün sind und in der Ausrichtung des SVD mit einer Sprache sprechen. Das ist auch schon gut. Und wenn jetzt so ein Mann wie Niklas Schmidt vielleicht auch ein paar Akzente setzen kann im Laufe der Rückrunde, warum nicht? Und ja, ich glaube noch nicht so recht dran, wie eingangs gesagt, dass Darnstadt da ein ernsthafter Contender ist bis zum Schluss, wenn so wäre. Warum nicht?
Das musst du mir nochmal– Entschuldigung, aber das musst du mir jetzt nochmal erklären. Also ihr spielt, habt erst zwei Niederlagen. Okay, ihr vergebt recht viele Top-Chancen. Also ihr schießt viele Tore, aber ihr könntet eigentlich, wenn man sich so die Chancenanzahl ansieht, vergebt ihr sogar recht viel auch. Also wenn da mal jemand gar nicht mehr trifft oder, ich weiß nicht, dann habt ihr ein Problem. Aber ich sehe das alles, was ihr da habt. Okay, Marc hat einen wichtigen Punkt, den hat ich gar nicht so auf dem Schirm. Stimmt, in der Breite des Kaders verletzen sich zwei, drei Eckpfeiler. Wird es vielleicht so wie Korridor oder Bader, dann wird es vielleicht eng. Aber ist das der Zweifel aus dem Understatement heraus?
Ja, vielleicht auch so. Man hat gesehen, was in der ersten Liga alles passieren konnte. Vor zwei oder drei Jahren waren wir auf einem Höhenflug. Der mündete fast zwangsläufig in dem Aufstieg. Dieses Jahr sieht das alles sehr stabil aus. Aber ich traue dem Braten noch nicht so recht. Dass man zwei Spiele von 19 verliert, ist bei mir die Frage, ist das Overperformance oder ist es einfach tatsächlich der Auswuchs dessen, was man leisten kann? Und die Hatta ist jetzt schon ein bisschen weit weg. Aber lasst die mal jetzt gegen Darmstadt gewinnen am Wochenende. Ich würde die Hatta noch nicht freiweg rausreden aus der Geschichte, aber zu denen kommen wir dann ja auch noch.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist jetzt die perfekte Überleitung. Ich habe ja nicht ohne Grund die Teams hintereinander gesetzt. Denn genug der Lobhudeleien, wenn man so möchte. Jetzt kommen wir zu den Teams, denen wir einen etwas negativen Rückrundenstart bescheinigen. All das ist ja auch, da muss man die Brisanz mal rausnehmen. Das sind zwei Spiele gespielt. Das ist nur ein Ersteindruck. Das kann sich alles noch ändern. Trotzdem bin ich jetzt gespannt, wie wir über Hertha reden werden. Denn ich kann ja vielleicht mal meinen Eindruck schildern. Denn ich stehe sehr ambivalent dazu, Hertha in den Negativbereich zu rücken. Rein ergebnistechnisch ist es so, dass Hertha ein 0 zu 0 gegen Schalke vorzuweisen hat und nun das 2 zu 2 gegen den KSC. Und auch da, die beiden Ergebnisse für sich genommen, sind, glaube ich, Ergebnisse, selbst wenn du dich von Anfang an als Aufschlusskandidat zählst, sind das Spiele, wo du sagst, das ginge schon in Ordnung. Im Vakuum gesehen. Ein Punkt gegen Karlsruhe, das ist kein Riesendrama. Und ein Punkt gegen Schalke aktuell sogar gut. Und wenn man sich dann sogar die Leistung dazu anguckt, dann stehe ich dann noch ambivalent dazu, denn das sind beide Spiele, in denen Hertha in meinen Augen sehr viel, sehr verbessert im Vergleich zu vielen Spielen dahin Runde aussah und beide Spiele verdientermaßen hätte gewinnen müssen. Gegen Schalke hattest du genug Torschancen und bist nur an dir selbst und Loris Karius gescheitert. Und gegen den KSC hast du dir, ja, hast du ein Tor selbst verschuldet, hast einen Sonntagsschuss von Sebastian Jung bekommen, der wirklich fantastisch war, scheiterst aber auch dann wieder eigentlich an dir selbst, indem du super viele Chancen liegen lässt. Und das ist sehr, sehr bitter. Und warum man sie dann wiederum aber in dieses Segment rechnen kann, ist, härter kann sich diese Spiele, in denen man sagt, ja, aber die Ansätze sind doch gut und naja, man kann sich doch vielleicht über einen Punkt nicht beschweren, weil sind ja auch Teams, die was können und ähnliches. Diesen Luxus kann sich härter nicht mehr leisten. Zum einen aufgrund des miesen Saisonstarts, in dem man sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr viele Punkte hat liegen lassen. Zum anderen, zum Ende aber ja auch der Hinrunde hat viel liegen lassen. Wenn wir uns die Spiele gegen Bielefeld, Fürth und Magdeburg angucken, da hat man zwei Punkte geholt von möglichen neuen. Gegen Teams, wo man gesagt hat, jetzt ist eigentlich der Zeitpunkt gekommen, um zu punkten und die Lücke nach oben zu schließen. Das heißt, den Luxus, sich Spiele leisten zu können, wo man über schöne Ansätze reden kann und über eine eigentliche gute Leistung, der ist eigentlich verpufft. Und nun sind es aktuell 7 Punkte auf Darmstadt, auf Platz 2. 6 Punkte auf Platz 3, Paderborn. Du willst ja eher Platz 2 als Platz 3, weil wissen wir alle, wie Relegationen zwischen 1. und 2. Ligisten oft ausgehen. Und dieser Blickpunkt ist wiederum wieder für gemacht, härter negativ zum Saisonstart zu sehen. Saisonstart, Rückgrundstart, sorry. Und das ist irgendwie eine Melange, die gar nicht so leicht auszufriemeln ist. Denn wie gesagt, man könnte jetzt auch über sehr viele positive Dinge reden, die in diesen zwei Spielen zu sehen waren. Aber Kevin, wie blickst du denn auf die Alte Dame?
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen das Ding der verpassten Möglichkeiten, bin ich bei dir. Also wenn du das erste Spiel siehst gegen Schalke, bist du ja schon drückend überlegen, aber schon. Du hast schon einen hohen Überschuss an Spielvorteilen gehabt auf deiner Seite. Spielst du das 0-0, machst das Tor halt nicht. Jetzt gegen KSC, ja zwei Rückstände quasi. Moralisch passt das, aber auch da, klar, war es eigentlich auch die bessere Mannschaft, wie du vorhin schon gesagt hast, in meiner Ansicht nach. Und hast es halt dann auch irgendwie durch, wie man immer so sagt, blöde Gegentore, die du selbst vermisst, weil du dann hinterher rennen musstest und dann nicht mehr die Power hast oder den Drive hast, dann noch das 3-2 irgendwie zum Altspiel ganz zu drehen. Ist halt auch blöd, ich meine, da ist der KSC dann schon gut genug, um dann auch so etwas über die Zeit vielleicht zu bringen. Ja, bin ich bei dir. Es ist irgendwie komisch, es sind in Anführungsstrichen zwei Siege und die oben sind ja auch nicht regelmäßig durchgehend am Gewinnen. Dann bist du wieder da drin in der Verlosung, kannst dann nochmal Momentum ziehen, aber jetzt gerade hast du wieder so den Anschluss verloren. Das muss man ganz ehrlich so sagen. Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach auch nicht der Anspruch der Hertha. Das wirst du besser wissen als wir. Man will natürlich wieder ins Oberhaus zurück und dadurch bräuchte man einfach mal ein bisschen mehr Konstanz. Wie gesagt, gegen Ende der Hinrunde hast du das Gefühl gehabt, jetzt sind sie auf dem Weg, sie haben jetzt so diese typischen Favoriten, Niederungen, die du da hast, durchwandert. Und jetzt werden sie schon nach und nach sich die Punkte einheimsen. Ja, schwierig, schwierig.
Und jetzt bist du seit fünf Spielen ohne Sieg.
Ja, krass.
Das ist übergreifend. Das vergisst man irgendwie, weil die letzten vier Spiele alle unentschieden waren. Hast jetzt aber eben auch, wie Stefan Leitl selbst gesagt hat, dir selbst den Druck erhöht durch diese Spiele. Du hast jetzt die Spiele gegen Darmstadt, Elbersberg, Hannover und Paderborn. Und hättest du mal die Siege jetzt gegen Schalke und den KSC, die auf der Straße lagen, mitgenommen, hättest du da vielleicht sogar den Luxus zu sagen, vielleicht da auch mal eher auf das Unentschieden gehen, wenn es spät in der Partie heikel aussieht oder ähnliches. Jetzt musst du in diesen Partien auf Sieg spielen. Anders geht es gar nicht mehr. Und ja, das wissen solche Gegner durch auch auch auszunutzen. Matthias, wie ist dein Blick auf Hertha?
Ja, schwierig. Also ich kenne das aus Fanperspektive, wenn man weiß, welche Gegner vor der Brust sind. Und man hatte im Herbst so einen Flow aufgebaut, dass man sich punkttechnisch schon viel weiter oben gewähnt hat, als dann die Mannschaft nachziehen konnte. Und gerade solche Spiele wie gegen Schalke oder Karlsruhe sind ja dann noch frustrierender. Auch vor dem KSC-Spiel hatte ja Leitl gesagt, Darmstadt hat gestern gewonnen, wir müssen eigentlich heute gewinnen. Haben sie nicht geschafft. Und das ist im Endeffekt wirklich tragisch, weil ich finde, das waren beides überzeugende Auftritte von Hertha. Und gegen Schalke hat es mich so ein bisschen an das Spiel in Lautern erinnert. Und nur damals hatten sie eben 1-0 gewonnen. Und gegen Schalke fiel dieses formale Deitetor nicht. Also war sehr, sehr ärgerlich, da Punkte liegen zu lassen. Und sie haben ja auch einen überwältigenden Spielansatz, der manchmal ja wirklich gut verfängt. Also wie jetzt Karlsruhe vor dem 1-1 unter Druck zu setzen, zu einem Fehlpass zu verleiten, dann innerhalb von drei Sekunden quasi einen Torabschluss und ein Tor zu machen. Und ich glaube, irgendwann auf Sky hatten sie auch gesagt, dass Hertha bis zur 60. Minute gerade mal 10 bis 11 Sekunden gebraucht hat, bis sie den Ball wieder zurückerobert haben. Also das heißt, da ist ja sehr viel Aufwand im Spiel. Und in letzter Konsequenz bringen sie den Ball aber nicht dahin, wo er am Ende landen muss. Also der Sportdirektor von Hertha hat ja auch vor dem Spiel gesagt, man plane jetzt erstmal nicht mit weiteren Verpflichtungen. Und wenn, dann muss er den Kader besser machen, der neue Spieler. Aber er muss natürlich auch finanzierbar sein. Also das heißt, Hertha hat jetzt mit dem Personal, vielleicht kommt doch noch irgendwo jemand, aber prima erst mal, sich auseinanderzusetzen, da das Maximum rauszuholen. Und die Spielanlage und der Spielvortrag finde ich, der stimmt. Aber der Ertrag in Punkt-zu-Tor-Erfolg und damit auch Punkt-Ausbeute, der stimmt eben nicht. Und da ist jetzt für mich auch die Frage, ist es einfach wie so eine Ketchup-Flasche, wo halt am Anfang wenig rauskommt und irgendwann gibt es mal 6, 7 Siege am Stück und dann ist man halt auch wieder da, wo man hin will.
Das gab es ja in der Hinrunde.
Ja, oder liegt das Problem tiefer? Da bin ich jetzt zu wenig drin. Man hat so Leute wie Demme nicht verfügbar, der einfach fast schon tragisch nicht so recht auf die Beine kommt. Dann mit Krattenmacher und auch mit Eichhorn jetzt erstmal Spieler, die man auch gut brauchen kann. Nicht. Dafür gefällt mir Cuisance. Das ist eigentlich ganz gut. Also er scheint sich auf die 2. Liga vollkommen eingelassen zu haben. Manchmal vielleicht ein bisschen übereifrig und über das Tier hinausschießend. Aber da ist schon viel da. Deshalb, Hertha ist für mich so ein bisschen– ja, du hattest am Anfang der Saison immer wieder den Begriff Black Box erwähnt, in puncto, wenn es darum ging, manche Teams einschätzen zu können. So ein bisschen ist es auch bei Hertha bei mir, weil da ist einfach viel angerichtet, aber es geht nicht so recht auf. Und dem braten traue ich noch nicht so ganz, aber wer weiß.
Das ist halt die große Frage, die auch in der Hinrunde gestellt war, so ein bisschen, liegt es am Trainer oder liegt es am Kader? Das stellt man sich ja oft die Frage. Und ich glaube, es gab schon Momente, wo man die Arbeit von Stefan Leithel oder generell dem Trainer-Team sehr kritisch gesehen hat, weil man eben wenig Spielidee erkannt hat, außer defensiv gut zu stehen. Das muss man ja schon sagen. Also Hertha war zwischenzeitlich das klar defensiv stärkste Team nach Schalke. Das hatte man zwischenzeitlich sehr gut hinbekommen. Wie gesagt, zum Ende der Hinrunde ein bisschen schleifen lassen. Jetzt sah das ja aber insgesamt auch wieder okay aus. Gehen den KSC mal so, mal so zumindest. Die letzten beiden Spiele zeigen für mich eher, dass es ein Kaderproblem ist. Denn Hertha hatte in diesen beiden Spielen eine sehr, sehr gute Spielanlage. Man hat sich sehr gut in den Räumen bewegt. Man wusste, wie man Positionen frei gespielt bekommt. Die Abstimmung mit und gegen den Ball war sehr gut. Dadurch ja auch das Pressing-Tor, was man da erzielt. Kevin Sesser, der den Ball abfängt. Und Fabian Reze, bei dem man das Gefühl hat, der ist irre schlecht in die Saison reingekommen. Er hat es sehr, sehr schwer. Er sah teilweise wie Schatten seiner selbst aus. Aber auch da, er kommt so langsam rein. Er macht jetzt auch Tore aus dem Spieler raus. Das hat ihm sehr lange gefehlt. Das Problem ist aber, du hast den Namen Diego Demme genannt. Der steht symbolisch für die Hala-Probleme. Hertha hat sehr viel Etat gebunden bei Spielern, die nicht zur Verfügung stehen oder nicht das leisten, was sie leisten müssten. Das kann Stefan Leithel nur bedingt ändern. Du hast das ganz große Problem, dass David Kufnatski als Unterschiedsspieler geholt wurde, aber ständig körperliche Probleme hat und deswegen bislang kaum zur Verfügung stand. Wenn er einigermaßen im Rhythmus war, hat man sofort seine Klasse erkannt. Er hat ja auch immerhin schon drei Tore erzielt. Aber es sollten so viel mehr sein. Warum Sebastian Gröning trotz einer OK-Torquote abgemeldet, das weiß man nicht so genau. Aber auf jeden Fall ist aktuell Luca Schuller der Stürmer Nr. 1. Er hat aber auch schon fünf Großchancen vergeben. Allein schon den K... Also er hätte gegen Schalke ein Tor machen können, das müssen und gegen den KSC zwei Tore machen müssen. Und das wird bei ihm mittlerweile fast schon von der Qualität zu einer Kopffrage. Weil irgendwann geht das in die Köpfe des Spielers hinein. Und das ist ein Riesenproblem. Du hast Spieler wie John Anthony Brooks, wie Diego Demme, wie Leon Jensen, wie Krattenmacher, lange Zeit Dudziak und Co., Spieler, die irgendwie in diesem Kader herumwabern, aber aufgrund von Verletzungen nicht zur Verfügung stehen. Viele Neuzugänge, die auch nicht so funktioniert haben, wie man sich das gewünscht hat. Man hat immer noch einen Thorstein-Sonnen. Man hat immer noch einen Kevin Sessa. Das war jetzt das beste Spiel von Kevin Sessa am Hertha-Trikot. Und es war ein ordentliches. Um mal da den Rahmen zu setzen, dabei wissen wir alle, dass Kevin Sessa ein Unterschiedsspieler in der Zeitliga sein könnte. Und dementsprechend muss man jetzt einfach sagen, man zahlt die Zeche dafür, dass über drei Jahre zu wenige Neuverpflichtungen funktioniert haben. Es sind fast alles Spieler, die jetzt funktioniert haben, die entweder vorher verpflichtet wurden oder aus der eigenen Jugend kamen. Also man ist eher über Kenneth Eichhorn gestolpert. Paul Seguin war halt der absolute Wunsch-Transfer von Stefan Leitel. Und man muss auch sagen, er hat das Niveau von Hertha angehoben. Aber darüber hinaus hat Benny Weber, ohne da jetzt zu tief gehen zu wollen, bis auf Toni Leisner, Michael Cuisance und Harris Tabakovic, keinen einzigen Spieler verpflichtet, der als Leistungsträger gelten kann. Fabian Reese wurde vorher schon verpflichtet. Wie gesagt, Spieler wie Martin Darday oder Ähnliches, die waren ja schon da. Und weitere haben ja den Verein verlassen im Sommer, wie Derry Sheeran, Marza, Kenny. Und man hat es nicht geschafft, da Spieler nachzuverpflichten, die Hertha zum einen besser machen, zum anderen aber auch zu der Idee von Stefan Leidel passen, der ein starkes Flügelspiel will, aber keinen gelernten Linksverteidiger bekommen hat, weshalb er irgendwann von Dreier- auf Viererkette umstellen musste und damit in Verteidigern gearbeitet hat. Bis auf Fabian Rehse und Martin Winkler hat man ehrlich gesagt keine Flügelspieler, weshalb Krattenmacher umfunktioniert wurde. Und jetzt Jerry Medutziak, zugegebenermaßen verrückterweise sehr, sehr gut nach anderthalb Jahren Pause funktioniert als Rechtsaußen. Eingeplant war er da nicht. So und deshalb empfinde ich diesen Kader als großes Stückwerk. Diese Suppe muss der Trainer ausdäufeln, ohne ihn da immer aus der Pflicht zu nehmen, aus der Kritik zu nehmen. Und trotzdem sehe ich, dass der Kader unter Stefan Dattel an klare Limitierungen stößt. Und das ist ein Riesenproblem. Und deswegen bin ich auch gespannt, ob sich das noch in der Rückrunde lösen lässt. Denn wie du gesagt hast, Kenneth Eichhorn wird jetzt wochenlang ausfallen, Boris Krattenmacher wird jetzt lange ausfallen, der auch immer wieder mal den Unterschied ausgemacht hat. Man muss beten und hoffen, dass Kovnatsky fit bleibt. Weil das ist dann der Spieler, der natürlich die Torchancen machen kann und dann dieses spielerische Übergewicht gegen Schalke, gegen den KSC auch mal in Tore hätte umwandeln können. So ist es unrund und ich habe aktuell klar das Bauchgefühl, dass Hertha am Ende die entscheidenden Prozentpunkte fehlen werden. Und das ist bitter, weil eigentlich das Feld bestellt war. Aber wie gesagt, man auch gewisse Unrundungen im Kader nicht innerhalb der Saison verändern kann. Und dementsprechend sind wir jetzt einfach mal gespannt, wie die nächsten Spiele sind. Ich habe sie ja schon aufgezählt. Allen voran, das Spiel ist natürlich dann gegen Darmstadt. Sollte Hertha dieses Spiel gewinnen, wie gesagt, dann sind plötzlich nur noch vier Punkte und dann ist man wieder in der Verlosung drin. Aber vollkommen klar ist, dass Hertha jetzt eine Serie braucht. Es sind jetzt noch 15 Spiele und Hertha muss eigentlich realistischerweise 10 dieser 15 Spiele gewinnen, um am Ende aufzusteigen. Und das will ich erst mal sehen. Aber genug zu dem Hertha-Schwerpunkt, würde ich sagen. Und wir gehen jetzt zu einem Team, was deutlich größere Probleme hat als Hertha, wenn man das so bezeichnen möchte, nämlich Greuther Fürth bzw. die Spielvereinigung Fürth. Greuther Fürth soll ja eigentlich nicht mehr gesagt werden. Da möchte ich mich gerne dran halten. Fürth, aktuell Tabellenletzter, die rote Laterne und es brennt tatsächlich lichterloh im Verein. Man hat ein verdientes 0 zu 2 gegen Dresden kassiert und ein schmeichelhaftes 0 zu 0 gegen Braunschweig. Es gab zuletzt ein Brandbrief des Aufsichtsrats und des Präsidiums, die die Mannschaft und die sportlich Verantwortlichen öffentlich angezählt haben. Das zeigt, wie sehr die Nerven blank liegen. Die drei Neuzugänge, unter anderem Paul Will von Darmstadt, Matthias, haben bislang auch noch nicht gezündet. Und so habe ich das Gefühl, dass der Trainer-Effekt auch schon wieder verpufft ist. Drei Punkte aus fünf Spielen unter Heiko Vogel sprechen eine relativ klare Sprache. Kevin, wie blickst du auf das Kleeblatt und auf diesen Rückrundenstart? Hast du jetzt überhaupt noch irgendeine Fantasie, dass sie am Ende die Liga halten?
Also, führt es wirklich gerade sehr. Also nicht nur gerade, sondern die ganze Saison schon und eigentlich auch schon davor. In der Saison wirklich ein Tiefpunkt her ab dem nächsten und es wird komplett konzeptlos, planlos. Teilweise hat man auch gar nicht mehr den Eindruck, dass irgendwer weiß, wer was zu bestimmen hat und wer was entscheidet und wen verpflichtet und nach welchem Konzept das getan wird. Mir fehlt die Fantasie, um das gerade mal so abzurunden, wie führt in dieser Saison, auch wenn unten alles sehr eng ist, das schaffen will. Also, ich weiß nicht, das Spiel gegen Braunschweig, das hast du auch nur 0-0 gespielt.
Hast du auch eine spürote Karte gesehen?
Braunschweig schafft es einfach nicht, Tore zu schießen. Das ist auch so ein, ist ja das andere Problem-Team irgendwie vielleicht auch. Also völlig ungefährlich gegen eine führte Mannschaft, die halt auch völlig ungefährlich und total verunsichert ist. Also da passt gar nichts zusammen. Also mir fehlt komplett die Fantasie, wie es Kleblat auch in der nächsten Zone, noch in der zweiten Liga spielen kann, soll. Aber das große Plus, was sie haben, ist einfach, dass das alles sehr eng beieinander ist. Und ein, zwei Momente reichen, um so ein Negativ-Trend auch komplett umzudrehen. Siehe Dresden gerade mit zwei richtigen Big-Points. Ja, aber ich weiß gerade nicht, wo es herkommen soll bei Fürth. Das ist so, sage ich schon.
Das ist aus der individuellen Offensivklasse. Du hast immer noch einen Furtkoll, immer noch einen Hürgota, immer noch einen Julian Green, einen Felix Klaus. Aber das sind ja die einzigen Strohhalme, die man hat. Weil defensiv habe ich das Gefühl, dass auch Heiko Vogel, auch wenn jetzt ein, zwei Defensiv-Transfers getätigt wurden, den Karren auch nicht aus dem Dreck ziehen kann. Sie haben einmal zu Null jetzt gespielt unter ihm. Das war jetzt eben dieses Spiel gegen Braunschweig. Was vielleicht auch eher daran lag, dass Braunschweig ein gewisses Unvermögen offensiv ausstrahlt. Also ich bin auch so ein bisschen, wir stehen ja auch immer wieder im Austausch mit unserem Fürth-Experten, Michi Fischer an der Stelle erwähnt. Der wirkt jetzt auch nicht gerade hoffnungsvoll. Matthias, hast du irgendeine Idee, wie das noch am Ende ein positives Ende nehmen soll?
Also da sind viele Zutaten bei Sam, die für einen Abstieg sprechen. Du hattest vorhin Paul Wilde erwähnt, der hatte jetzt gleich wohl kaum Möglichkeiten, sich an den Vereinen, an den Kader zu gewöhnen. Der wurde, glaube ich, am Mittwoch transferiert. Auf jeden Fall im Laufe der Woche hat er am Samstag gleich durchgespielt. Der ist ein Spieler, der einer Mannschaft schon Rückhalt geben kann, der viel läuft, der sehr gutes Passspiel hat und der einer Mannschaft vielleicht in so einer verunsicherten Situation was geben kann, was sie braucht. Allerdings, das Spiel gestern gegen Braunschweig war für mich fast ein Muster ohne Wert, weil es einfach über 90 Minuten in Unterzahl war. Da kann man nicht so recht draus was ableiten, finde ich. Dennoch würde ich das als ein Punktgewinn für die Moral verzeichnen. Irgendwann hatte ich zwischendrin auch so ein paar Vibes. In der Hinrunde am ersten Spieltag hat der Braunschweig in Magdeburg 1-0 gewonnen, in Unterzahlen mit einem Glückstreffer. Da hatte ich schon so gedacht, nach einer Stunde immer noch 0-0, vielleicht gibt es ja was Ähnliches für Fürth. Und dann hatten sie ja sogar zwei relativ gute Gelegenheiten, die einen Treffer verdient hätten, wäre schmeichelhaft gewesen, aber warum nicht? Dennoch, ich hatte von den Zutaten gesprochen, ich fand, dass nach der Niederlage in Dresden der Trainer relativ dünnhäutig reagiert hat. Also Heiko Vogel hat da nach der Partie nicht mit Kritik gespart, hat auch davon gesprochen, wir werden die Zügel anziehen, ein anderer Wind wird wehen und da war er gerade erst im vierten Spiel da. Also das erschien mir eher oldschoolig und nicht im positiven Sinn. Wenn man zu solchen Wutreden ansetzen muss, das spricht nicht dafür, dass Mannschaft und Trainer sich hier sonderlich nahe stehen oder irgendwie zueinander gefunden hätten. Gestern wiederum, als Dietz in der ersten Minute mit einer roten Karte vom Platz musste, da hat er ihn dann auch gleich in den Arm genommen, als er vom Platz ging. Das erschien mir dann schon wieder eigentlich ein ganz gutes Zeichen. Aber alles in allem, ich meine 44 Tore zur Halbserie, dann zwei gegen Dresden, das ist einfach viel zu anfällig. Wenn sie die Defensivprobleme nicht in den Griff kriegen, dann können sie vorne für den Abstiegskandidaten relativ viele Tore schießen. Das wird nicht fruchten. Dass sie jetzt viel Mittel verfügen, um sich in letzter Konsequenz in der letzten Reihe zu verstärken, sehe ich jetzt erstmal auch nicht. Und wenn natürlich auch noch, wie du schon sagtest, Aufsichtsrat und Präsidium mit draufhauen, puh, also Wagenburg und Schulterschluss sieht anders aus. Deshalb bin ich auch wenig verwunderlich, nicht davon überzeugt, dass das eins ins andere greift und dann in den Klassen erhalten mündet. Und ich hatte mir gerade noch mal als Kevin über Furt gesprochen, hat er angeschaut, wer so die letzten Jahre da war. Also wenn man irgendwie die Trennung von Zorniger vor 15, 16 Monaten sich erinnert, ruft nach einer 04-Klatsche gegen Klub, das will kein Furt-Trainer erleiden. Damit war seine Zeit zu Ende, aber da waren sie nicht irgendwie in der Abstiegszone. Und seitdem kamen Jan Sievert und Thomas Kleine und sie sind für mich seitdem permanent in der Abstiegszone und irgendwann wahrscheinlich vielleicht die Substanz aufgebraucht. Und Heiko Vogel ist für mich einfach nicht der richtige Mann. Ich mag mich täuschen, aber er ist jetzt keiner, der in den letzten Jahren sonderlich viel, glaube ich, auf sich irgendwie positiv im Profifußball vereinen konnte. Vielleicht sehe ich ihn auch falsch, aber irgendwie…
Nee, das ist so. Ich glaube, er hatte so eine sehr gute Saison mit Basel. Ansonsten…
Die ist auch schon lange her, ne?
Sie wissen, sich seine Trainerstation nicht erfolgreich. Sie haben sie eher aus der Versenkung geholt. Und ich glaube, mit Alexander Zorniger zusammen muss man ja auch die Trennung zum Beispiel auch von Azusi nennen. Seitdem habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass… Auch da, es gab sicherlich Anlass für Kritikpunkte, aber seitdem hat sich ja nichts verbessert. Also habe ich das Gefühl, dass man das Gefühl hatte, wir trennen uns von dem einen Mann und dann wird alles, dann wird es durch Handauflegen besser. Aber darunter hat man halt kein neues Konzept etabliert. Ich finde, Kevin hat es ja schon erwähnt, es ist nicht ersichtlich, nach welcher Idee da jetzt gerade gearbeitet wird. Stefan Fürstner wird konstant überfordert. Hatte ja vorher auch so eine Rolle noch nicht inne. Ich finde es auch irre orientierungslos. Es gab ja auch diesen Brandbrief der Fans, die gesagt haben, hier geht es ja nicht nur um den Abstieg, also geht es um die Existenz des Vereins. Man kann ja auch alle Jugendmannschaften, die zweite Mannschaft angucken. Keine Mannschaft von Fürst performt in irgendeiner Weise. Man steht finanziell so schlecht da wie lange nicht mehr. Also es gibt ja keinen Aspekt, wo man sagt, darauf kann man irgendwas zukünftiges fußen lassen. Und deswegen bin ich, also man muss ja um ganz viert fürchten, sollte es zum Abschied kommen, weil dann keine Substanz vorhanden ist.
Also wenn...
Aber das führt vielleicht ein bisschen weit.
Aber wenn sie es schaffen sollten, die Gründe, wie gesagt, erschließen sich mir überhaupt nicht, wie das gehen soll, weil es wirkt total zerrüttet, wie ich schon gesagt habe. Wenn sie es schaffen sollten, müssen sie trotzdem einen Neuanfang im Sommer starten, weil das, was da gerade ist...
Das, glaube ich, mindestens das wissen sie selbst.
Ja, gut. Aber das hätten sie eigentlich... Also das ist, wie du sagst, das hat sich die letzten Jahre schon angekündigt. Und ja, also da fehlt mir einfach die Idee. Es ist so platt, wie es sich anhört. Es fehlt mir die Idee. Und jetzt ist halt wieder nur noch mit Durchhalteparolen und Aurok-Aktionen irgendetwas möglich. Oder wie Matthias sagt, mit so einem schmutzigen 1-0-mal, da gewinnst du drei, ein Dreier holst du auf einmal unerwartet irgendwo. Aber wie gesagt, die brauchen Siege. Und zwar nicht zu knapp. Wenn du gesprochen hast, die Hertha braucht zehn. Also Führk braucht jetzt auch erst mal eigentlich zwei, drei in Folge oder... Also vor allem gegen eine Mannschaft wie Braunschweig, die halt selbst das Tor nicht findet.
Wie gesagt, da spielt die Rote Karte natürlich eine große Rolle. Aber sehen wir auch davor viele wie gegen Düsseldorf und so verloren. Also die direkten Duelle waren da. Jetzt hat man gerade vier Punkte Abstand auf das rettende Ufer und auf Platz 16. Die nächsten Partien werden eine immens wichtige Standardbestimmung. Du spielst zunächst gegen Kiel, die ja auch nicht komplett aus der Verlosung sind, wenn auch am komfortabelsten noch. Und dann spielst du gegen Magdeburg, die ja zwar per se in der Tabelle nicht super gut dastehen, aber natürlich mit das formstärkste Team dieser Liga aktuell sind. Wenn man jetzt mal diese Derby-Niederlage gegen Dresden ein Stück weit ausklammert, also da hast du jetzt richtig Druck. Mal sehen, ob wir bei dem nächsten Team ein bisschen mehr Fantasie haben, ob sie die Klasse halten können. Die haben diese Nullnummer mitproduziert gegen Fürth. Das war nämlich Eintracht Braunschweig. Vielleicht auch weniger das Spiel als das davor. Auch diese klare und sehr, sehr, sehr verdiente 0 zu 3 Heimniederlage. Auch noch gegen Magdeburg. Wie gesagt, Magdeburg bei aller Berücksichtigung der Formstärke des FCM. Glaube ich, dass dieses Spiel schon sehr kritisch gesehen werden muss. Jetzt auch in Kombination mit dieser Nullnummer gegen indispronierte Fürther in Unterzahl. Matthias, wie blickst du auf die Braunschweiger, die ja in der Saison auch immer wieder bewiesen haben, dass sie in kritischen Momenten auch wieder da sein können. Das muss man ihnen ja zugute halten in der Hinrunde. Glaubst du, die können das Kunststück in der Rückrunde wiederholen?
Also wenn zumindest jemand Abstiegskampf erprobt ist in der 2. Liga, dann wohl Eintracht Braunschweig, die sich natürlich gerne mal von da hinten früher raushalten wollen würden. Grüße an Anna. Aber im Moment sieht es nicht so aus. Auch das Torverhältnis von minus 12. Es könnte eine kleinere Hypothek darstellen. Also der Rückrundenauftakt ist auf jeden Fall in die Hose gegangen, glaube ich kann man sagen, weil gegen Zehnviertel über die komplette Spielzeit schlussendlich keinen Torerfolg zustande zu bringen. Das zeigt schon, wo ein bisschen der Hase im Pferfer liegt. Also Braunschweig ist eine Umschaltmannschaft und wenn eine Mannschaft sich hinten mit einem Bus vor dem eigenen Tor wiederfindet, dann wird es schwer. Gleichwohl in der 2. Liga werden nicht alle den Bus parken. Aber es ist einfach zu wenig Durchschlagskraft. Wir erinnern uns, sie haben vor der Winterpause Schalke geschlagen. Da macht man sich den zwei Spielen jetzt wundern, wie das zustande gekommen ist. Gegen Magdeburg eindeutig unterlegen. Magdeburg hat gespielt, wie man Magdeburg früher kannte. Und vielleicht sind sie ja wieder auf dem Weg dahin. Aber das war schon... Man hat sie auch gelassen. Also das war ernüchternd aus Braunschweigers Sicht, vor allem zu Hause. Und jetzt in Fürth spielen sie es halt einfach auch nicht gut aus. Also sie haben es vor der Pause mal geschafft, ein paar Gefahrenmomente herauf zu beschweren. Da konnte man von Pech reden, dass da nicht mit 1-0 in die Pause gegangen wird. Aber in Summe war das viel zu ideenlos, viel zu wenig durchschlagskräftig. Und man hat jetzt Conté verloren in der Winterpause, der jetzt auch kein Torgarant war. Aber ich finde, er hat dem Spiel schon manche Momente gegeben, die einfach wichtig waren und er aus sich heraus konnte die kreieren. Jetzt hat man Ali-Doo geholt. Und der war gegen Magdeburg. Da hatte ich ein bisschen auf ihn geachtet, wie so ein Fremdkörper noch ein bisschen im Spiel. Gegen Viert kam ich gar nicht dazu, ihn zu beobachten. Keine Ahnung, ob er überhaupt im Spiel war.
Er wurde nach 68 Minuten eingewechselt.
Ja, siehst du mal. Also da glaube ich, würde ich im Moment den Pick wagen. Das war jetzt nicht der Spieler, der ihnen sonderlich weiterhilft. Und du hattest auch gemeint, sie haben mal so Phasen, wo sie punkten. Also sie haben so kleinere Läufe und dann aber auch wieder längere Durststrecken. Und ich fühle mir immer noch dieses Pokalspiel gegen den VfB vor Augen, als Braunschweig wirkte wie ein besserer Erstligist. Und jetzt doch so eine ernüchternde Saison zu spielen, finde ich alarmierend. Also ich sehe Braunschweig...
Was ich alarmierend finde, ist, wir sehen das und dann sehen wir Heiner Backhaus, der in jedem Interview nichts ankreidet, außer Mentalität. Also er wird ja nicht müde zu sagen, vor jeder Taktik kommt Mentalität und Einsatz. Das ist mir einfach inhaltlich viel zu dünn. Ja, das reicht in manchen Partien. Und es gibt mal den einen Tag, da stehen die alle mit dem richtigen Fuß auf und sind den einen Zacken frischer als der Gegner. Und dann funktioniert das mal. Aber du musst auch was darüber hinaus bieten. Aber da kommt ja gar nichts. Und das finde ich auch gemessen daran, dass Braunschweig seit Jahren da unten hängt und seit Jahren ja nur über Intensität und wir müssen es mehr wollen kommt, hat man sich offensichtlich für den nächsten Trainer entschieden, der das vielleicht ein bisschen innenbrünstiger vermittelt bekommt als seine Vorgänger, aber letztendlich genau dasselbe fordert und genau denselben Spielstil fordert. Und das ist inhaltlich, finde ich, so unwahrscheinlich dünn. Und deswegen gewinnst du dann solche Spiele wie gegen Viertnich, wo es mal drauf ankommt, irgendeine Idee zu haben. Die muss ja nicht mal fantastisch sein, aber ab irgendeine Idee. Und dazu kommt natürlich, du hast den magischen Namen schon gesagt, sie haben mit Christian Conté vielleicht den Unterschiedspieler ihrer Mannschaft verloren, der zusammen mit mir mit Aydin sowohl die meisten Tore, als auch die meisten Vorlagen abgegeben hat bisher in der Saison, 4 und 3, um genau zu sein. Ich verstehe, dass du als Braunschweig eine Ablösesumme wie 1,5 Millionen Euro nicht ablehnen kannst, vor allem, wenn der Vertrag des Spielers ausläuft im Sommer. Trotzdem ist Farid Alidou nicht die zufriedenstellende Antwort, beziehungsweise nicht alleine, wenn es Alidou wäre und man holt noch zwei andere Spieler mit dazu, um es in der Breite vielleicht aufzufangen, um unberechenbarer zu sein. Da könnten wir drüber reden, das ist ja aber nicht geschehen. Und wie gesagt, nichts ist teurer als ein Abstieg. Dem muss man sich bewusst sein, dass, wenn man den Unterschiedspieler in der Offensive abgibt, dass das deutlich mehr Wahrscheinlichkeit in sich trägt, wieder abzusteigen. Ich finde es irre, uninspiriert auf dem Feld. Also Intensität allein ist keine Spielidee, ich sage es immer wieder. Da hat z. B. Fennich Dynamo Dresden etwas voraus. Das sieht einfach deutlich mehr wie Fußball aus, abseits von Intensität, was Dynamo ja ausmacht. Und wenn du dann so reinstartest, weiß ich auch nicht, ob die Spieler im nächsten Spiel dran glauben, 110% für die vermeintliche Spielidee zu geben. Also das funktioniert ja auch über Ergebnisse, dass du dann brennst und den Gegner nieder rennst. Das hat der Schalke auch oft bewiesen. Es kann reichen am Ende, weil so viele Teams da unten drin hängen. Das kann schon reichen. Boah, es ist aber echt kritisch. Du spielst jetzt gegen Karlsruhe. Da kann alles passieren, habe ich das Gefühl. Absolute Wundertüte, das Spiel. Und danach spielt sie gegen Bielefeld, die mit unten drin hängen. Hui, also das sind, glaube ich, zwei Standortbestimmungen tatsächlich, weil danach spielt sie eher gegen Darmstadt, Elbersberg. Aber das sind wichtige Partien. Bis dahin muss einem schon ein bisschen Angst und Bange um Braunschweig sein, finde ich.
Ich kann auch gestern, also man hat dieses Spiel, in dem man sich gegen ein dezimiertes Team zunehmend schwerer tut und der Kopf wird schwerer. Man hat überhaupt keine Lösung. Und dann wechselt man 90 Sekunden vor Schluss Florian Flick ein. Dann wundere ich mich, was soll das? Also ich hätte jetzt gedacht, man wechselt ihn ein, weil er mit 1,90 vielleicht hohe Bälle verwertet, ablegt oder sogar ins Tor buxiert. Aber doch nicht 90 Sekunden vor Schluss, vor Abschluss der vor Ablauf der Nachspielzeit. Also den Wechsel, der hat sich mir 0,0 erschlossen, weil wenn ich den Siegtreffer herbei beschweren will und sehe in Florian Flick eventuell eine Personalie, die das tun kann, dann mache ich es doch früher, nicht in der 93. Minute oder so. Ja, schwierig.
Schwierig ist nicht als Geduld.
Und dafür bleiben irgendwie ein Robert Ramsack, der Mittelstürmer ist auf der Bank, ein Fabio Kaufmann, der vielleicht mal den Einsprint anziehen kann. Ja, also weiß ich auch nicht. Wie gesagt, Braunschweig unter der Backhaus lässt mich so ein bisschen ratlos zurück bislang. Aber ich glaube, das wird auch bis zum Saisonende so bleiben. Heißt aber nicht, dass jetzt schon irgendein Urteil gefällt ist. Wie gesagt, sie haben ja ihre Phasen, wo es dann vielleicht doch funktioniert und wo sie vielleicht die entscheidenden Prozentpunkte gehen können. Apropos entscheidende Prozentpunkte, die hat Preuß Münzer bislang nicht gefunden zum Rückgrundstart. Stattdessen gab es bislang zwei Niederlagen. Zum einen das bereits erwähnte 0 zu 2 gegen den KSC. Und nun haben sie– ja, Kevin, du hast das live gesehen– das 2 zu 1 gegen Paderborn kassiert. Rutschen, wie ich finde, eher still und heimlich in so eine Krise. Also sie sind jetzt seit fünf Spielen ohne Sieg. Wie gesagt, jetzt auch gegen Paderborn hat sicherlich die frühe rote Karte, die maximal dämlich übrigens war. Also ich weiß nicht, wie man da mit den beiden so lange so oben stehen bleiben kann. Zieh es zurück, dann passiert da gar nichts. Du kriegst höchstens Geld, weiter geht's. Also total vermeidbar. So aber bringst du dich in die Situation, nach einer Führung sogar noch das Spiel zu verlieren. Wenn ich mal vorgreife, ich kriege Minster nicht so richtig gegriffen. Ich finde diese Kaderqualität an einigen Stellen echt cool. So die Batista Meyers dieser Welt. Gleichzeitig ist es an anderen Stellen auch überhaupt nicht gut besetzt. Sie suchen ja anscheinend verzeichnet auch noch einen Mittelstürmer, weil die Chancenverwertung nicht stimmt. Defensiv ist es aber auch nicht gut. Sie haben erst ein einziges Mal zu Null gespielt in der Saison. Sie kassieren sehr oft nur ein Gegentor, aber das kassieren sie halt. Ich finde Münze optisch nie so richtig verkehrt, aber auch selten so richtig gut. Deswegen tue ich mich total schwer, sie zu greifen. Kevin, du hast sie heute gesehen, wenn auch dezimiert. Was für ein Bild machen die auf dich?
Tja, was für ein Bild machen die auf mich? Eins, was mit einem Blitzstart eigentlich gut in das Spiel in Paraborn reingekommen ist. Klar, wäre auch komisch, wenn nicht mit so einem schnellen Tor. Und dann, wie du sagst, eigentlich ein Spiel auf Augenhöhe gestalten als Auswärtsteam, bei einem SC Paraborn, der sich die letzten Jahre schon auch ein anderes Standing erarbeitet hat und erspielt hat. Und dann diese, ja ich weiß auch nicht, also warum dieses Foul begangen wird von Yasi Pashma gegen Obermeier, grobes Foulspiel, völlig, also auch in der Position völliger Quatsch. Ich habe ihn auch nicht im Interview gehört oder in einer Aussage dazu gehört, ob er sich komplett verschätzt hat. Ich habe es auch nicht wirklich greifen können, warum das passiert. Und ab dem Zeitpunkt ist ja klar, dass es dann schwierig wird mit einem SC Paraborn, der halt Tempo geht, der Kombinationsspiel hat usw. Und sofort alle Attribute, die halt eine Mannschaft hat, die oben mitspielt. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Und dann kassierst du halt zwei Gegentore noch. Und das war dann eigentlich sogar noch zu wenig. Weil man aus Münster-Hanar-Sicht natürlich auch ein bisschen Pech, dass der Keeper dann irgendwie krank rausfällt und so weiter. Also irgendwie Münster hat immer so kleine Dinge drin, die es verhindern, dass sie sich konstant erspielen und erarbeiten. Sie haben dann immer wieder einen Rückschlag. Das heißt, der Torwart fällt aus oder irgendwer anders. Eine rote Karte, die man auswärts überhaupt, also zu Hause auch nicht gebrauchen kann. Aber du gehst früh in Führung, kannst entspannt eigentlich aufspielen. Und ja, versammelt es mit eigenen Verfehlungen. Es ist nicht so, dass der SC Paderborn das erzogen hat zu dem Zeitpunkt, finde ich. Sondern das war völlig unnötig, dass du den SC Paderborn so wieder ins Spiel reingebracht hast und quasi auch eine Vorteilsituation gebracht hast.
Man ist jetzt mit 20 Punkten nur 15. Einzähler vom 16., 2. vom 17. und hat jetzt auch wichtige Spiele gegen Nürnberg, Bochum und Düsseldorf.
Sie versuchen halt immer mutig nach vorn zu spielen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das dann im Abstiegskampf nachher zu mutig ist. Also sie haben ja, das muss man sagen, auch in Unterzahl heute ein super expectes Goals wert gehabt mit 1,6. Das ist nicht schlecht, finde ich. Vor allem, wenn man in Unterzahl agiert. In aggressiven, mutigen Fußball, das ist alles eigentlich das, was man gerne auch belohnen würde, weil es ist nicht immer langweilig und unattraktiv, ihnen zuzugucken. Tja, aber jetzt Nullpunkte nach der Pause, Platz 15, rote Karte, fehlende Kaltschnäuzigkeit, das kann man auch bei Münster, glaube ich, als Attribut reinwerfen.
Matthias.
Also, die spielen eigentlich wie ein Geheimfavorit, aber die Ergebnisse sind wie ein Abstiegskandidat. Das ist irgendwie ganz komisch bei Münster.
Zumindest zunehmend. Sie haben ja durchaus die zeitlichen Spiele drin gehabt.
Also, sie punkten wie ein Absteiger, ja.
Nee, stimmt. Also, sie haben 6 Punkte in den letzten 8 Partien geholt. Ende Oktober und Sie gegen Kiel. Seither nur noch einer gegen Bielefeld. Und was du sagtest, Marc, ich glaube, da liegt schon der Funken Wahrheit drin. Sie haben einfach in vorderster Front nicht die Spieler, die knipsen. Also, Sie haben im Kader, wenn wir es uns mal vor Augen führen, Oskar Wilhelmsson, den kennen wir aus Darmstadt, der ist ein Spieler mit Potenzial, aber er ist einfach zu häufig verletzt. Also, schlussendlich wahrscheinlich mehr verletzt als verfügbar. Malik Badmas hat einen Kreuzbandriss, Etienne Amenidou kennen wir auch, ist keiner, der eine Saison verlässlich durchspielt überhaupt und dann schon gar nicht erst verlässlich trifft. Also, Sie müssten, glaube ich, auch, wenn Sie jetzt die letzte Woche nutzen wollen, in der Sturmabteilung nachlegen.
Es gibt Gerüchte, also Sky berichtet, dass Sie Jessica Nuncombe ausleihen wollen, den ich ja noch sehr gut aus Berlin kenne, eigengewächs, aber er passt in dem Sinne perfekt zu Preußen Münster, weil Jessica Nuncombes Körper gefühlt nicht für den Profifußball gemacht ist, so bitter muss ich es ausdrücken, weil dieser Junge jetzt mit 25 Jahren wirklich alles schon mal sich verletzt hat, schon Ewigkeiten ausgefallen ist. Sicherlich ein Spieler, der durch Kampf, Dynamik, Intensität ein Spiel irgendwie auf seine Seite ziehen kann, aber bislang auch nicht als der absolute Knipser bekannt, eher so ein arbeitender Stürmertyp, deswegen auch manchmal auf dem Flügel geparkt. Ja, Münster wird auch jetzt nicht mehr die Crème de la Crème bekommen, das ist auch klar und trotzdem, finde ich, passt Nuncombe ironischerweise sehr gut zu den Preußen an.
Also gehen wir mal davon aus, es wird sich noch was tun und ansonsten fand ich, die Niederlage gegen den KSC und auch schon die Partie vor Weihnachten zu Hause gegen Elbersberg so ein bisschen eine Blaupause von beiden. Also sie hatten in beiden Spielen genug Möglichkeiten gegen Elbersberg, war es ein 1 zu 1, das Spiel zu gewinnen. Und das eine verlieren sie und das andere spielen sie unentschieden, also hatten deutliches Chancen plus. Sie sind ja auch eine Mannschaft, die einen gepflegten Ball spielen kann. Sie hatten einfach oder sie treten für mich, für ein Team, das jetzt erst die 2. Saison der 2. Bundesliga spielt, treten sie mit einer spielerisch beeindruckenden Selbstverständlichkeit auf und waren gegen den KSC eindeutig hier im Haus und befreien sich auch aus Pressingssituationen. Da kriege ich schon manchmal Schnappatmung. Das funktioniert aber sehr gut. Und dann kriegen sie einen Platzverweis schon gegen den KSC, der das Spiel zum Kippen bringt. Und jetzt gegen Paderborn haben sie auch sich einen Berndienst geleistet mit einem Platzverweis. Also er erinnert so ein bisschen an Braunschweig im Laufe der Hinrunde, die auch Platzverweise wie andere sonst was gesammelt haben und sich da selber im Weg standen. Und Münster wäre es wirklich zu wünschen, dass sie rechtzeitig wieder das Glück auf ihrer Seite haben. Weil ich glaube, da ist schon viel angelegt in der Mannschaft. Und ich hoffe, sie verlieren jetzt nicht den Kopf und werden irgendwann noch über den Trainer diskutieren müssen, weil das ist oftmals auch nicht per se die Lösung. Und dass sie ihrem Stil treu bleiben, aber einfach einen richtigen Abschlussspieler kriegen, der ihnen dann auch die Punkte garantiert. Das würde ich mir, obwohl ich keinerlei Münster-Bezüge habe, aber ich weiß es zu schätzen, wenn jemand versucht, sich über spielerische Elemente was drauf zu schaffen und nicht nur über schnellen Umschaltfußball. Also wenn sowas fruchtet, fände ich es gut. Und was wir vielleicht abschließend noch erwähnen sollten, Christian Panda ist jetzt Präsident inzwischen bei Preußen Münster, wurde zum Jahresbeginn vom Aufsichtsrat zum Präsidenten gewählt. Also nicht die Mitglieder wählen den Präsidenten in dem Klub, sondern der Aufsichtsrat. Auch interessant.
Ich glaube, bei Union ist das auch so. Das gibt es ab und zu mal. Also ja, da gibt es verschiedene Modelle. Matthias, Kevin, da haben wir doch mal zum Rückrundenstand einen richtigen E-Post hier abgeliefert. Zwei Stunden über den Start der zweiten Liga. Mal gucken, wer bis zum Ende hört. Gerne mal in den Kommentaren melden. Würde uns total freuen. Ich habe mich darüber gefreut, dass ihr die Zeit mitgebracht habt, Matthias, Kevin. Vielen lieben Dank. Ich drücke ja auch schon mal auf das Outro. Hat großen Spaß gemacht. Ich hoffe, wir konnten ein bisschen Insights liefern über Edin Dzeko hinaus. Soll ja über alle Teams geredet werden. Ansonsten wisst ihr, Rasenfunk unterstützen, Supporters Club, guckt vorbei. Und ansonsten macht's gut. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschau.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.